I'M OKAY. FOR ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO OUR
MARCH SEVENTEENTH INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON SAFE AND EQUITABLE
RE OPENING OF SPORTS TIME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SHARON QUIRK
SILVA AND I AM GLAD THAT WE ARE
HERE TO FIND OUT MUCH MORE
ABOUT HOW WE CAN GET. OUR
ATHLETES PLANE AGAIN. I BEFORE
WE BEGAN AND WE HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF HOUSEKEEPING AS YOU MAY
NOTICE WE ARE PARTICIPATING-
AND PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SCENE IN THIS HEARING
ROOM. AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CAPITOL BUILDING WE HAVE
LIMITED PHYSICAL SPACE IN THIS
ROOM FOR PEOPLE TO WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON BUT WE
ENCOURAGE. THOSE WATCHING ON
THE ASSEMBLY WEB PAGE TO CALL
IN DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SEGMENT OF THIS HEARING THE
NUMBER TO CALL CAN BE FOUND ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE OR ON THE
SCREEN LATER. OR DURING THIS
HEARING. THIS IS THE THIRD IN A
SERIES OF HEARINGS THIS
COMMITTEE WILL HOLD ON THE
IMPACT OF CLOVEN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IN ON THE PEOPLE AND
BUSINESSES IN. CALIFORNIA'S
ARTS TOURISM AND SPORTS
INDUSTRIES. THE FIRST HELD IN
OCTOBER WAS AN EXAMINATION OF
THE ECONOMIC POWER AND
RESILIENCE OF CALIFORNIA'S.
TOURISM INDUSTRY WHERE THE
COMMITTEE SOUGHT TO GAIN
INSIGHT INTO THE CHALLENGES
FACING CALIFORNIA'S TOURISM
INDUSTRY INDUSTRY DURING THIS
UNPRECEDENTED TIME. THE SECOND
HEARING WE HAD WAS JUST LAST
MONTH AND THAT WAS TITLED
RESTARTING THE ARTS BEST
PRACTICES FOR SAFELY RE
OPENING. THIS PROVIDED A FORUM
FOR MUSEUMS GALLERIES AND
PERFORMANCE VENUES TO SHARE
THEIR EXPERIENCES WITH THE POPE
IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC ESPECIALLY
THE IMPACT OF THE STAY AT HOME
ORDERS ON THEIR BUSINESSES AND
STAFF AS WELL AS THE ARTISTS
THEMSELVES. TODAY'S HEARING
WILL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
CULVER NINETEEN GUIDELINES
GOVERNING CALIFORNIA SPORTS
PLANS FOR SAFELY RE OPENING
SECONDARY AND POST SECONDARY
ATHLETIC. TITLE NINE
CONSIDERATIONS LESSONS LEARNED
FROM PROFESSIONAL SPORTS AND
THEIR FUTURE PLANS FOR COVERT
NINETEEN SAFETY AS WELL AS
RECREATION AND YOUTH SPORTS
PLANS. FOR RETURNING TO
COMPETITION. WE WANT YOU TO
KNOW HOW THE EFFORTS OF THE
GOVERNMENT HAVE HELP SO FAR
WHAT YOU NEED AND WHAT WE CAN
DO TO BE OF GREATER ASSISTANCE.
WE ARE ALSO SOLICITING BEST
PRACTICES FOR RE OPENING SPORTS
FROM THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO REOPEN EITHER IN OTHER
COUNTRIES OTHER STATE OR UNDER
THE GUISES DINA MINISTRY TO.
ORDERS ISSUED BY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. YOUR
EXPERIENCES WILL BE VERY
HELPFUL FOR OUR MEMBERS TO HEAR
AS WE MOVE INTO OUR SECOND.
LEGISLATIVE SESSION UNDER THIS
PANDEMIC. AS YOU CAN SEE THE
GENDER IS JAM PACKED WITH
EXPERTS IN ALL RANGES OF THE
SPORTS COMMUNITY INCLUDING
PROFESSIONALS AND RECREATIONAL
SPORTS THEREFORE I WILL CLOSE
MY REMARKS ARE AN ASSET AS YOU
PRESENT YOUR REMARKS THAT YOU
LISTEN CAREFULLY TO OTHERS. AND
ADD YOUR OWN SPECIAL COMMENTARY
BUT TRY NOT TO REPEAT. WE'D
ALSO LIKE YOU TO MAKE SURE YOU
STAY ON TIME WITH YOUR REMARKS
AND THIS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE CAN GET TO THE ENTIRE AGENDA
IN A TIMELY WAY. ALSO FOR
MEMBER WE TO HEAR FROM YOU WE
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
STAY ON TIME. AT THIS TIME IDO
WANT TO JUST MAKE A FEW NOTES
BEFORE WE START PERSONAL NOTES.
I TOO WAS AN ATHLETE AND JUNIOR
HIGH AND HIGH SCHOOL BEING A
NOT ONLY A COMPETITIVE SWIMMER
BUT A WATER POLO. AND LADIES I
CAN TELL YOU IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THERE WAS NOT A
WATER POLO WOMEN'S TEAM SO WE
HAVE COME A LONG WAY. AND I
WANT TO REACH OUT AND SAY TO
ALL THE STUDENT ATHLETES. YOU
ARE IN OUR HEARTS WE KNOW THAT
THIS HAS BEEN A DRAMATIC YEAR
FOR YOU. WE KNOW IT'S CERTAINLY
NOT HAVE HAS NOT BEEN PART OF
YOUR HIGH SCHOOL PLAN AND WE
WANT TO GET YOU BACK ON THOSE
FIELDS AS SOON AS WE CAN. AND
WITH THAT I'M GOING TO ASK IF
WE CAN FIGURE. MEMBERS HERE
WOULD HAVE ANY BRIEF COMMENTS
AND WE HAVE- WE WILL INVITE OUR
VICE CHAIR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
ALL THEIR **** THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PANELISTS FOR BEING HERE
TODAY INCREASED PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY AMONG CHILDREN AND
ADULTS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS. TO DO THAT WE
CAN DO TO IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES IN CALIFORNIA.
CHILDREN WHO ARE ACTIVE TURN
INTO ACTIVE ADULTS AND CHILDREN
WHO AREN'T ACTIVE DO NOT TURN
INTO ACTIVE ADULTS- LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE I TOO WAS A- AN AVID
BASKETBALL PLAYER WILL I WAS
ABOUT SOME OF HER IT WAS A HIGH
SCHOOL. AN ATHLETE AND IT
REALLY DID OPEN UP SO MANY
DOORS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR ME
I HAD DREAMS OF THERE BEING A
pSCHOOL THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN BUT
EVENTUALLY THE W. N. B. A. WAS
BORN. AND WE HAVE COME SO FAR
IN TERMS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS IN
ATHLETICS AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THAT
AND THAT PASSED AWAY. I'M EVEN
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC.
ONE THE OTHER THINGS THAT I.
THANKS SO CONCERNED. THROUGH
THIS HAND IN THE PRIOR TO THIS
KIND OF WAS AMONG CHILDREN
OBESITY RATES ARE AN ALL TIME
HIGH AND SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
AMONG LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN CHILDREN A RECENT
STUDY SHOWED THAT CHILDREN WHO
DON'T EXERCISE ARE TWICE AS
LIKELY TO HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS AS CHILDREN WHO DO.
AGAIN THIS PANDEMIC HAS ADDED
TO THIS ON THE ANXIETY THAT WE
SEE IN CHILDREN- THIS GROWING
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS WE NEED TO
GET CHILDREN TO BE ACTIVE
AGAIN. WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
GREATEST INDICATOR OF POSITIVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES IS SOCIO
ECONOMIC STATUS AND COLLEGE AND
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS HAVE BEEN A
BIG ECONOMIC BUT PRINT HAVE A
BIG ECONOMIC FOOTPRINT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO I AM HOPING TO
HEAR FROM SOME OF THE PANELISTS
ON HOW THE INDUSTRY'S ADJACENT
TO COLLEGE AND PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS WOULD BE IMPACTED. BY RE
OPENING WITH FANS HOTELS
RESTAURANTS VENDOR PARKING-
SPORTS IS A IS A BIGGER
ECONOMIC ENGINE THAT I THINK
THAT WE REALIZE. AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEAR MORE
ABOUT THAT. AS WE CAN TO REDUCE.
OUR CASE THREE AND ACCESS TO
BOX WE NEED TO ALSO BE
PROACTIVE IN GREEN LIGHTING ALL
LEVELS OF SPORTS AS WELL SO I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS ROBUST
CONVERSATION I APPRECIATE ALL
OF OUR PANELISTS- AND THE LAST
THING THAT I WILL MENTION IS- I
SPENT TIME AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT ALL TO THE- AUTISM
SPEAKS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WHO
PUT ON AN ANNUAL A WALK THAT
RAISE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
THE AUTISM COMMUNITY. THE
SPORTS INDUSTRY. AND THE
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT USE SPORTS
OPPORTUNITIES TO BRING IN
REVENUE TO HELP OUR COMMUNITY
IS VAST AND IT'S SOMETHING I'M
LOOKING FORWARD. I'M TO
LEARNING ABOUT HOW WE CAN GET
YOU BACK TO WHERE YOU NEED TO
BE AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEXT WE HAVE
NEW TO OUR COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RICHARD BLUM AND IF YOU
WANT TO SAY WHERE YOU REPRESENT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A LOT OF
INDUSTRY IN YOUR AREA. THANK
YOU WESTSIDE'S BEDSIDE DOWN IN-
IN IN L. A. I. LIVE IN SANTA.
AND REPRESENT THE SURROUNDING
COOKING. BOB A MAN. VICE CHAIR
I REALLY JUST WANTED SAY HEALTH.
I TO BE BACK- SERVING ON THIS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT COMMITTEE-
I. LOOK AT THIS MY SECOND STINT
ON ON THE COMMITTEE- AND- I
THINK- THE ARTS ENTERTAINMENT
SPORTS TOURISM INTERNET YOU
THINK ABOUT THE BUCKETS OF- OF
THE ECONOMY. THAT IS
REPRESENTED BY THIS COMMITTEE
AND THERE'S- LITERALLY NO
COMMITTEE AND THE- IN THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT I THINK IS
MORE IMPORTANT TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. IN OUR IN OUR
STATE. OF ALSO VERY VERY-
PLEASED TO. HEAR THE VICE CHAIR
TALKING ABOUT INTERESTS AND-
OBESITY SOMETHING THAT- THAT I
HAVE. CHAMPION AND. UP AND-
INVOLVED IN AND INTENSE
INTEREST IN US SINCE ARRIVE
HERE AND SO I LOOK FORWARD.
WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU AND
ACCOMPLISHING CUSTOM IMPORTANT
THINGS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND AS A MEMBER CHOI DID
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS. THANK
YOU CHAIRPERSON FOR INVITING
AND- THIS COMMITTEE IS SUPPOSED
TO BE UP. ALSO AND THE PAYMENTS
POLLS OF TORY AND THE INTERNET
MEET I WE OUGHT AND HALF OF THE
WORD. AND TODAY IS- FOCUSING
UPON NOW- SAID AND ACT WILL RE
OPEN THE BOYS. ARE JUST A VERY.
IN I HAD UP. A LOT OF OUR
QUESTIONS AND- HOPEFULLY
THROUGH TODAY- IN FOR OR HE WE
CAN. COME UP WITH A SOME. AND
THE HELPFUL IN PARTICULAR ARE
NOT MY IS- IS IT K. TO TWELVE.
OSCAR SO TO OPEN A SQUARE AS
FAR. AND THE OLD ANOTHER SOLVE
ALL ON SCHOOLS SPORTS. OR TO BE
ALL. UP THE EVERY IF YOU HAVE.
THE ALL THE PER. TEAMS ARE THE
BEST EVEN SO WITHOUT THE YOU
KNOW SPECTRUM- HAVE ALL. AND
HOW MUCH. THEY ARE DOLLARS SO
HOW MUCH CONTACT ARE VERY COME.
THE IT IN THE OR PLAY IS
SELECTED A MUCH MEDIA NAY.
VALUE YOU KNOW HOW EXPRESS THEY
ARE. BUT THEY WERE EXT. TO PLAY
WITH THE IN OUR NECK OF WHAT
FISCAL OF CONTACTS. TAKE IN A
SCORE SPORTS OR SHOULD BE OPEN
THERE ARE MANY MANY- PARENTS-
KNOCKING ON MY DOOR ON THE SAME
TOPIC AND THEN ALSO EVEN ON OUR
ON OUR GO AHEAD OF SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS- A CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION MEMBERS SO-
MEETING. WITH THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS- ALL OF THE DIFFERENT-
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- AND THAT THAT
WAS ALL IN ALL ALL ON ONE OF
THOSE SMALL AREAS THAT THAT WE-
TALKED ABOUT THE- SO- WITH.
THIS OF PERIOD OF. OF VACCINES
ALSO AVAILABLE AND- MOST
TEACHERS SO ARE ENCOURAGING THE
TO GET THE FAXES AND IN PERSON
LEARNING AND THE CONTEXT OF-
SHOULD BE- VERY SOON OPEN AND-
AT THE SAME TIME WE NEED TO
ENCOURAGE AND ALLOW. ALL THE
CONTEXT BOSA FOR THE SCHOOLS SO
ARE TO OPEN AND- OUR NON SCHOOL
AREA. AND ALLOWING THE PLAYERS
TO PLAY AT THE SAME TIME
LIMITING EVEN. IF UNPOPULAR-
THE CATEGORY OF- DISTRICTS- THE
WILL ALLOW LIKE A 20% OFF FOR
SPECTATORS YES 20% 50% IF TO
SELL INDOOR OUTDOOR AND THEY
CAN HAVE A SOCIAL DISTANCING
EVEN MORE THAN SIX. YOU KNOW
FEET AWAY BUT THAT WILL. FILL
UP BOB APPLAUDED YOU KNOW LIKE
HALF OF THE STADIUM. ONCE YEAR
INSIDE OR OUTDOORS BUT THE WAY
THAT THE US NUMBER COME FROM IN
VERY LIMITED IN ON NUMBER ABOVE
PEOPLE ALLOW THAT THAT MAKES
THE MOST SENSE TO ME SO I THINK
THAT WE HAVE LEARNED OVER THE
YEARS. HOW TO LEAVE- SAFELY
WITH HIS CELL CORBETTA IN
PARTICULAR WITH THE VACCINES-
NOW BEING INOCULATED SO. I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE THAT THE
POINT OF AND- I ENCOURAGE YOU
ALL FULL OR DISCOURSE OF TO
OPEN AND- A SPECTATOR'S OPEN
AND- I'VE TO MENTAL- IMPACT. OF
CLOSING DOWN EVERYTHING AND
EVEN STUDENTS AT HIM ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL STUDENTS SO THIS A
COMMITTING A SUICIDE AT THAT
RATE IS EVEN HIGHER THAN- ARE
THE PEOPLE THE YOUNG CHILDREN
DYING FROM COLD WITH HIS SELF
SO YES I THINK WE NEED TO. OPEN
UP A WITH A SAFE GUIDELINES OF
THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED THANK
YOU DR CHOI AND WITH THAT I
BELIEVE WE DO HAVE OTHER
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMITTEE ON WEB
ACCESS AND I KNOW. LISTENING
MANDER WEBEX WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVID CHIU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN LAURA FRIEDMAN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADRIN NAZARIAN
IF ANY OF YOU ARE OUT THERE ON
OUR WEB BACKS AND WANNA MAKE
SOME VERY VERY BRIEF COMMENTS
WE WANT TO GET RIGHT BACK ON
TRACK OR YOU. CAN MAKE COMMENTS
AFTER EACH PANEL. DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY FROM WEB ACTS AS A
MEMBER. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND START RIGHT AWAY
OUR- PANEL AND SPEAKER AS I
KNOW- SOME OF OUR SPEAKERS ARE
IN A VERY SHORT TIME LINE. OUR
FIRST PANEL IS GUIDELINES
GOVERNING CALIFORNIA SPORTS IN
TITLE NINE CONSIDERATION WE
HAVE OUR FIRST SPEAKER DR ERICA
PAN. WHO IS THE STATE M. A. D.
ALL AGES DEPUTY DIRECTOR CENTER
FOR INFECTIOUS DISEASE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND WE WELCOME DR ERICA
PAN. HEY GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU ALL SO MUCH- IN ORDER TO BE
WITH YOUR COMMITTEE THIS
AFTERNOON- AS MENTIONED I'M DR
ERIC UPON I'M THE STATE
EPIDEMIOLOGIST- ALSO
PEDIATRICIAN BY TRAINING AND
I'M ALSO A PARENT- AND I JUST.
WANT TO RESONATE THAT I WAS A
HIGH SCHOOL SWIMMER AND PLAYED
A WOMEN'S WATER POLO IN COLLEGE
AS WELL SO I AM AN ATHLETE AS
WELL AND I DO UNDERSTAND- THE
IMPORTANCE AN ATHLETE YOU KNOW
PULL THE IMPORTANCE OF EXERCISE
AND U. SPORTS- TO OUR PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH- I CONTINUE
TO TRY TO BALANCE THAT WITH
THE- OTHER- IMPACT OF THIS
PANDEMIC- MORE RECENTLY JUST AS
FAR AS ATHLETICS- I'VE SORT OF
TERMS THAT. THAT PRIOR HISTORY
INTO- LEASE AGAIN PRE PANDEMIC
WHEN I HAVE TIME- AND MY
TRANSLATE- SO JUST TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR OUR YOUTH
SPORTS GUIDELINES THAT WE'VE
HAD FROM THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
HEALTH AGAIN WE RECOGNIZE
IMPORTANCE ABSOLUTELY OF
CHILDREN'S PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH. AND OUR APPROACH HAS
BEEN WORKING TO BALANCE THOSE
BENEFITS AGAINST COVE IN
NINETEEN RISKS. AS CASE RATES
OF HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE
DECLINING ACROSS CALIFORNIA NOW
WE ARE ALLOWING OUTDOOR HIGH
AND MODERATE SPORTS COMPETITION
TO BEGIN WHILE COUNTIES ARE IN
THE PURPLE OR RED HERE. WITH
MODIFICATIONS AND STEPS TO
REDUCE RISK IN COUNTIES WITH
THE CASE RATE AT OR BELOW.
FOURTEEN CASES PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER DAY. AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW VERY NINETY WE HAD
REALLY SOME. GUIDANCE FOR AND
REC SPORTS AND THAT KIND INTO
FOR ON FEBRUARY TWENTY SIX. WE
THEN FURTHER UPDATED OUR
GUIDANCE ON MARCH FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND OUR GUIDANCE
APPLIES TO YOUTH SPORTS IN
GRADES K. THROUGH TWELVE AND
SCHOOLS COMMUNITY SPONSORED
RECREATIONAL CLUBS WORDS
ORGANIZE USE WORDS- AND THEN WE
ALSO WANTED TO HAVE CONSISTENCY
ABOUT THE PRINCIPLES LEVEL OUT
LOW MEDIUM AND HIGH RISK
CONTACTS WORDS- AND- SO ALSO
PUT FOR THE ADULT. RECREATIONAL
SPORTS AS PART OF THAT OVERALL
GUIDELINES- THESE GUIDELINES DO
NOT APPLY TO COLLEGIATE OR
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS. I DO WANNA
MENTION AS WELL JUST AS FAR AS
CONTACTS AND THEN THINKING
ABOUT SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE- WE'RE
WELL ON OUR WAY TO VACCINATION
A VERY EXCITING THAT WERE OVER
TWELVE MILLION DOSES IN
CALIFORNIA AND OVER FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE FULLY
VACCINATED. WE SHOULD KEEP IN
MIND THOUGH THAT THERE IS NOT
YET A PEDIATRIC APPROVED
VACCINE- WE DO KNOW THAT TWELVE
TO SIXTEEN YEAR OLDS ARE BEING
ENROLLED IN TRIALS NOW I THINK
THAT THAT AGE RANGE TWELVE TO
SIXTEEN YEAR OLDS WE MAY HAVE
ACCION'S LATER THIS YEAR- BUT-
WE ARE JUST NOW. LITERALLY JUST
AND REPORTED YESTERDAY THE
FIRST TIME THAT KIDS UNDER THAN
TWELVE YEARS OLD. THEY'RE GOING
TO BEGIN TO DO TRIALS SO WE MAY
NOT SEE CHILDREN'S VACCINATED.
UNTIL YOU KNOW MUCH MUCH LATER
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE OR EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT HERE IN
MINE AS WE THINK ABOUT THE
RISKS TO OUR CHILDREN. OF
ESPECIALLY HIGH RISK CONTACTS
SPORTS THE OTHER THING I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT- YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE RARE BUT REALLY
IMPORTANT INTEREST CONSEQUENCES
OF COVERT NINETEEN WELL AGAIN
MANY CHILDREN- YOU KNOW DON'T
HAVE SERIOUS IMPACTS ARE CAN
HAVE. HAD NO SYMPTOMS AT ALL
WE'VE HAD THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY CONFIRMED MULTI SYSTEM
INFLAMMATORY SYSTEM AND
CHILDREN CASES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND FOUR OF THOSE CHILDREN DIED
AND OVER HALF OF THEM WERE
ADMITTED TO THE INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
LONG TERM OUTCOMES- AND SOME OF
THE MIDDLE LONG TERM IMPACTS
THAT WE ALL WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE PREVENTING WHEREVER WE
CAN. I WANT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
HAVE THAT- ALSO TOP OF MIND AS
WE THINK ABOUT AGAIN WEIGHING
THE DIFFICULT DECISION THE
BOUNCES OF SPORTS- AND WHAT'S
WHAT YOU CAN DO. SAFELY AS FAR
AS PHYSICALLY DISTANCE MAKING
SURE PEOPLE WEARING FACE
COVERINGS ALL THE TIME- LET'S
SEE A FEW OTHER COMMENTS- SO.
SPORTS THAT ARE. WE AGAIN THEM
INTO THE DIFFERENT CAT. AS FAR
LOW MEET AND HIGH CONTACT. AND
THEN YOU CAN SEE BASED ON WHAT
TEARS- WE HAVE DIFFERENT RULES
AND OUR OUR GUIDANCE IN THE
TABLE. AND IT'S AGAIN BASED ON
THE LEVEL CONTACT PARTICIPANTS
CAN HAVE WITH EACH OTHER. AND
ONE OF THE SPORT IS PLAYED
INDOORS OR OUTDOORS. HOPEFULLY
YOU ALL AREHEARING OUR MESSAGE
IS LOUD AND CLEAR THAT ANYTHING
OUTDOORS AS MUCH LOWER RISK AND
THINGS THAT ARE INDOORS INDOORS
IS VERY HIGH RISK- CONDITIONING
PRACTICE FOR ALL SPORTS ARE
CONSIDERED LOW RISK IF THEY CAN
BE OUTSIDE AND- AND- PEOPLE
REMAIN DISTANCED- AND AGAIN
WEARING A MASK OR FACE
COVERING. INCLUDING DURING
CONDITIONING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT I KNOW EARLY ON.
PEOPLE HAVE SAID THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO EXERCISE WEARING A
MASK I ACTUALLY WEAR A MASK NOW
WHEN I RUN AND I DO THINK
PEOPLE CAN GET USED TO THAT. SO
EXCEPT FOR THINGS LIKE OUR
WATER SPORTS AND OTHER PLACES
WE REALLY ARE WANTING PEOPLE TO
GET IN TO IMPROVE THEIR SAFETY
TO BE WEARING FACE COVERINGS
DURING- DURING CONDITIONING AND
ADD DURING PRACTICE AND
COMPETITION UNLESS IT'S A
HAZARD- SEE IF THERE'S OTHER.
HIGHLIGHTS WANTED TO MAKE SURE
SO AS FAR AS HUMAN ERROR
COMPETITION JUST TO HIGHLIGHT
THE CURRENT GUIDELINES. CANTOR
TEAM COMPETITIONS. RESUME IN
CALIFORNIA BEGINNING JENNER
TWENTY FIFTH AND IT'S BASED ON
THE GUIDELINES AGAIN AN
ARTISTIC ITEMS. THE STATUS OF
RETURN TO COMPETITION IS
SUBJECT TO CHANGE AT ANY TIME
GIVEN A WHATEVER LEVELS
ATTENTION WE HAVE. A NO
TOURNAMENTS OR EVENTS THAT
INVOLVE MORE THAN TWO TEAMS MAY
OCCUR. EXCEPTIONS MAY BE MADE
OF AUTHORIZED BY THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT IF THERE ARE
SPORTS WHERE INDIVIDUAL
COMPETITORS FROM MULTIPLE TEAMS
ARE ROUTINE- SOME EXAMPLES OF
THAT MIGHT BE TRACK OR FIELD.
CROSS COUNTRY GOLF- SKIING OR
SNOWBOARDING OR TENNIS. AGAIN
THINGS WERE THERE INDIVIDUALS
COMPETING- YEAH JUST ONE ALSO
REITERATE WE STILL HAVE OUR
CALIFORNIA TRAVELED WAS
REPLACED TRAVEL OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR COMPETITION IS
NOT ALLOWED- THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL MULTI STATE AND MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL OUTBREAKS HAVE
BEEN REPORTED WITH. A TURN OF
EVENTS OR- OR SPORTING EVENTS
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN ALLOWED OR
INDIVIDUALS TRAVELING TO OUT OF
STATE COMPETITION SO WE HAD A
LOT OF TOPICS RELATED TO THAT-
I JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON THE
TEST REQUIREMENTS AS WELL THAT
CAME UP MORE RECENTLY. THE
TESTING IS REQUIRED FOR SOME
SPORTS AND STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
OTHERS. BECAUSE FOOTBALL RUGBY
AND WATER POLO ARE HIGH CONTACT
SPORTS THAT ARE LIKELY TO BE
PLAYEDON MAST. WITH CLOTHES
FACE TO FACE CONTACT EXCEEDING
FIFTEEN MINUTES OR JUST VERY
CLOSE AND READING HEAVILY IN
EACH OTHER'S FACES. WEEKLY
TESTING IS REQUIRED FOR ALL
PARTICIPANTS AGED THIRTEEN AND
OVER. AND COACHES IN COUNTIES
WITH THE CASE RATE BETWEEN
SEVEN TO FOURTEEN PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND. FOR COMPETITION TEST
RESULTS MUST BE MADE AVAILABLE
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
PLAY. AND THEN OUTDOOR MATER
CONTACT SPORTS SUCH AS BASEBALL
CHEERLEADING AND SOFTBALL CAN
BE PLAYED IN THESE COUNTIES
WITHOUT THE TESTING REQUIREMENT.
US MAYBE ALL BECAUSE OF THEIR-
AND I'M NOT SURE I'M TAKING
QUESTIONS OUR LATER. I THINK
I'M DOCTOR PAN AYE I KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE BEEN WORKING
TIRELESSLY ON- NOT ONLY
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU HEAR EVERY DAY BUT PIVOTING
ONE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ONE AREA
AND I'LL JUST JUMP A LITTLE BIT
OUT OF ORDER HERE. THAT IS
WE'VE BEEN CONTACTED- MORE THAN
A FEW TIMES RELATED TO IF YOU
WANT TO CALL THEM THE CHARITY
RUN GARAGE GROUPS OR GROUPS.
THAT MIGHT WHETHER IT'S THE
TURKEY TROTTER THIS USING
CHROME AND TYPE OF RUNS OR
SMALLER FIVE KAYS JUST ALL OF
THOSE- IF YOU CAN GIVE US ANY
UPDATE THERE OR IF WE COULD
HEAR ABOUT ANY PLANS THAT
THERE'S POSSIBLE BECAUSE THEY
FEEL LIKE THERE HAVEN'T BEEN
GIVEN- GUIDELINES THAT. THEIR
TAX WORKING FOR THEIR IN. YEAH
ANNA THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
WE- HAVE ALSO BEEN CONTACTED OF
COURSE AS WELL AND WE DO HAVE
THOSE KIND OF HONOR DR WE'RE
WORKING ON SOME GUIDELINES
AROUND THAT I'M THINKING ABOUT
WHEN THAT COULD BE SAFE- AND
HOW THOSE CAN BE DONE SAFELY-
SO I THINK IT IS- WE'RE KIND OF
DOING A LOT OF THE- MOST
RECENTLY UPDATED BLUEPRINTS- AS
FAR AS- OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
FORTHCOMING SUCH AS OTHER
EVENTS AND- SOME OF THE LARGER
KIND OF EVENTS- INDOOR SPORTS
AND OTHER. PROFESSIONAL SPRTS
GUIDELINES AND I THINK SOON
AFTER THAT WILL BE FORTHCOMING
WITH OTHER GUIDELINES ON THOSE
KINDS OF EVENTS. THANK YOU I
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT PLANNING AHEAD
OF TIME WHERE. THEY NEED A GOOD
AMOUNT OF TIME TO. PUT ON AN
EVENT. UP WITH THAT I THINK DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE THAT HAS A
QUESTION- BECAUSE DOCTOR PAN
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO STAY FOR
THE ENTIRE. PROCEEDINGS SO ONE
ONE QUESTION FROM OUR- VICE
CHAIR. AND IT'LL IT'LL BE QUICK
SO DOCTOR PAN DO YOU- BUNCHES A
PAID. OR IS THE ADMINISTRATION
WORKING ON ANY GUIDANCE-
OUTDOOR GREEN TIER WHEN. WE CAN
GET BACK TO YOU KNOW 1100%
CAPACITY. AND YOU KNOW 1100%
PARTICIPATION AND WHAT IS THAT
TIMELINE LOOK LIKE. YES WE ARE
DEFINITELY ACTIVELY WORKING ON
THAT- AND HOPING TO HAVE-
SOMETHING AROUND THAT THE BILL
THE VERY SOON- AGAIN WE'RE
FOCUSING ON A LOT OF THESE-
MOST RECENTLY ANNOUNCED UPDATE
THAT ARE FORTHCOMING- BUT WE
HOPE TO HAVE UPDATES ON US FOR
THE GREEN PHASE IN THE VERY
NEAR FUTURE. THANK YOU SURE
THANK YOU DR PAN WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND THAT IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WE CAN
SEND THOSE INTO HER AND SHE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO STAY AFTER
THIS THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVING.
OKAY ALL RIGHT NEXT WE HAVE
WITH US. THE TWO SPEAKERS
ELIZABETH CHRISTIAN AND KIM
TURNER FROM THEY ARE BOTH
PROJECT DIRECTORS FOR FAIR PLAY
FOR GIRLS IN SPORTS A PROJECT
OF LEGAL AID WORK- AND THIS
WILL BE RELATED TO TITLE NINE
WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN AND THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING US HERE
THIS AFTERNOON TO TALK ABOUT
THIS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH KRISTIN AND I AM A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AND I
DIRECT THE GENDER EQUITY AND
LGBTQ RIGHTS PROGRAM AT LEGAL
AID AT WORK- LEGAL AID AT WORK
IS A HUNDRED AND FIVE YEAR OLD
NONPROFIT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M JOINED TODAY BY KIM
TURNER DIRECTOR OF OUR FAIR
PLAY FOR GIRLS IN SPORTS
PROJECT I'LL SPEAK FIRST AND
THEN WE'LL- WE'LL TRY AGAIN IN
JUST A LITTLE WHILE I WAS
PLEASED TO HEAR ABOUT EVERYONE
TALKING ABOUT THEIR SPORTS
BACKGROUND I TO HAVE A STRONG
CONNECTION TO SPORTS. I PLAYED
BASKETBALL IN JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL AND IT
WAS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
AND SOME OF THESE ISSUES ARE
ALSO PERSONALLY NEAR AND DEAR
TO MY HEART. AND I KNOW WE HOPE
EVERYONE HAS A SAFE AND AS WELL
AS POSSIBLE DURING THESE REALLY
DIFFICULT TIMES- AND I WANT TO
THINK AGAIN THE COMMITTEE AT
STAFF AND OUR CO PANELISTS FOR
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING TODAY.
FOR NEARLY TWO DECADES OUR FAIR
PLAY PROJECT HAS HELPED GIRLS
AND YOUNG WOMEN OVERCOME GENDER
INEQUALITY IN SCHOOL AND PARKS
AND RECREATION ATHLETIC
PROGRAMMING. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SHARING WITH YOU OUR
PERSPECTIVE ON GENDER
INEQUALITY IN THE RE OPENING OF
YOUTH SPORTS. AND MORE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT PRINCIPLES
OF GENDER EQUITY HAVE TO BE
KEPT IN MIND AS SPORTS RE OPEN
IN CALIFORNIA. THESE PRINCIPLES
ARE IMPORTANT BOTH BECAUSE
GENDER EQUITY IS REQUIRED UNDER
FEDERAL LAWS LIKE TITLE NINE.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE GIRLS AND
WOMEN HAVE BEEN DENIED EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY IN SPORTS FOR
GENERATIONS SO IT'S BOTH
LEGALLY MANDATED. BUT ALSO PART
OF OUR CORE SHARED VALUES AS A
STATE TO ENSURE A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD FOR GIRLS AND WOMEN. AND
THROUGH LITIGATION TRAINING AND
POLICY WORK FAIR PLAY ADVOCATES
FOR GENDER EQUITY IN YOUTH
ATHLETICS WITH A SPECIFIC FOCUS
ON THE MILLIONS OF GIRLS IN PRE
K. ELEMENTARY MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL ACROSS CALIFORNIA. BUT
ALL TOO OFTEN EXPERIENCED
SECOND CLASS SPORTS
EXPERIENCES. ARE NO SPORTS
OPPORTUNITIES AT ALL COMPARED
TO THEIR MALE PEERS. THIS
CORROSIVE MESSAGE OF INEQUALITY
FOR GIRLS CAUSES LIFELONG
HARMS. AND CONVERSELY MAKING
SURE THAT GIRLS HAVE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY DEVELOPS GIRLS
CONFIDENCE AND AFFORDS THEM A
LIFE LONG BENEFITS I KNOW. SOME
OF YOU ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THE
HEALTH BENEFITS FROM
PARTICIPATING IN SPORTS.
THERE'S ALSO A BETTER
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES IN ADULT
EMPLOYMENT SUCCESS FOR EXAMPLE
GIRLS WHO PLAY SPORTS IN HIGH
SCHOOL EARNED 7% HIGHER WAGES
LATER IN LIFE. FAIR PLAY SEEMS
TO BE ABOUT ACT FOR GIRL.
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN LOW INCOME
CAN. AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
WERE GIRLS HAVE THE FEWEST
SPORTS OPPORTUNITIES OF ALL
THEIR GIVE PEERS. TITLE NINE
THE FEDERAL LAW PROHIBITING SEX
DISCRIMINATION IN FEDERALLY
FUNDED EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES INCLUDING SCHOOL
SPORTS HAS BEEN A LOT FOR
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS. AND IN
CALIFORNIA JENNER EQUITY IN USE
COMMUNITY SPORTS RUN OR HOSTED
BY YOUR LOCAL PARK AND REC
DEPARTMENT. HAS BEENREQUIRED
BY AB TWO FOUR FOUR NOTICE THE
FAIR PLAN ACT FOR MORE THAN
FIFTEEN YEARS. BEFORE TITLE
NINE FEWER THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND GIRLS ARE PLAYING HIGH
SCHOOL SPORTS NATIONWIDE AND
NOW THERE ARE MORE THAN THREE
MILLION GIRLS PLAYING HIGH
SCHOOL SPORTS. YOUR VOICE STILL
HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA STATISTICS IMPROVE
THE PANDEMIC TIMES GATHERED BY
THE CALIFORNIA INTERSCHOLASTIC
FEDERATION. MEMBER STATES HIGH
SCHOOL CHAU BOYS GETTING A
HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PLAY SPORTS
COMPARED TO GIRLS DESPITE GIRLS
WANTING TO PLAY MORE. AND
FURTHER MORE GIRLS TO DO PLAY
SPORTS ARE OFTEN RELEGATED TO
SUBPAR FACILITIES RESOURCES AND
TREATMENT. UNFORTUNATELY WHEN
GIRLS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COACHES TRY TO SOLVE
THESE PROBLEMS AT THE SCHOOL
LEVEL. THEY ARE TO OPT IN OR
RETALIATED AGAINST AND SUCH
BACKLASH FOR COMPLAINTS IS NOT
PERMITTED UNDER TITLE NINE
COMPLAINTS SHOULD BE WELCOMED
IN A DRESS. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THESE MATTERS DURING
AND AFTER THE PANDEMIC. AND
FAIR PLAY IS HERE TO HELP. WITH
THAT. WE WOULD LIKE TURN TO OUR
SPECIFIC CONCERN. AND I'M A
GREAT FOR ME ABOUT HOUSE
RIPPING CAL. IS GOING FIRST
GENERAC WITTY. I PLAYED IN SOME
DURING THESE PANDEMIC TIMES
ATHLETIC INEQUITY. TUMBY
EXACERBATED FOR EXAMPLE GIRLS
AND BOYS TEAMS ARE HAVING TO
SHARE ALREADY STRAINED AND
OVERBOOKED FACILITIES THERE
SHARON COACHES THAT ARE
MANAGING SEVERAL TEAMS SPORTS
IN THE MIDST OF THESE COMPRESS
YOU SENSE. THIS FORCED SHARING
OF ATHLETICS FACILITIES
COACHING AND RESOURCES RAISES
THE REAL THREAT THAT ITS GIRLS
WILL BE TREATED AS SECOND CLASS
CITIZENS THEY'LL BE PRACTICING
AND PLAYING AT THE WORST TIMES
GETTING LESS ATTENTION COMPARED
TO BOYS SPORTS. AND INFERIOR
ACCESS TO THE STRING RESOURCES.
GRAYSON THEIR TEAMS HAVE NOT
BEEN PRIORITIZED IN REOPENING
TO THE SAME EXTENT AS BOYS
SPORTS IMMERSING SHORTER
SEASONS FOR EXAMPLE. AND JUST
GLANCING AT THE LAST YEAR OF
NEWS ARTICLES AND COVERAGE AND
OUTSIZED LEVEL OF ATTENTION HAS
GONE TO BOYS FOOTBALL AND OTHER
BOYS SPORTS SUCH AS BASEBALL
AND BASKETBALL GETTING BACK TO
PLAY. WITH LITTLE TO NO MENTION
OF GIRLS SPORTS RESUMING AND
THE IMPACT OF THE POTS AND
FEMALE TEENS. WE MUST REMEMBER
THAT USE ANSIBLE SPORTS ARE
ABOUT EDUCATION AND YOUTH%
DEVELOPMENT YOUTH ATHLETIC
EXPERIENCES SHOULD BE
ACCESSIBLE AND EQUITABLE FOR
ALL REGARDLESS OF GENDER. AND
I'D LIKE TO NOW TURN THIS TO
CAN TURNER TO CONTINUE REMARKS
THANK YOU AND AGAIN I'M JUST
SAYING. AGAIN I'M GONNA
REMINDER SPEAKERS WE NEED TO
KEEP TO THE TIME LIMITS
INCREDIBLE COMMENTS. ELIZABETH
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SRE WE
STAY ON TRACK. A WELCOME CAN'T.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- JUST ONE TO
YOU KNOW AS OTHER MENTIONED
MENTIONED I AM LIKE LONG AFTER
BALI PLAYER. HIGH SCHOOL
VOLLEYBALL PLAYER PRODUCT OF
PARKS AND RACK AND OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM SO THANK YOU
EVERYONE. FOR THIS TIME SAID IN
THIS ATTENTION- BUT STILL
TURNING OUT TO COMMUNITY YOUTH
SPORTS IN TERMS OF OUR UNDER
RESOURCE FOR PARKS AND
RECREATION AGENCIES WE'RE
SEEING THEM STRUGGLING. TO
REINTRODUCE YOUTH SPORTS WHILE
SERVING AS A SAFETY NET FOR
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES
MUCH LIKE THE BELEAGUERED
SCHOOLS WE'RE SEEING EXPENSIVE
PRIVATE. CLUB SPORTS THAT ARE
OFTEN USING PUBLICLY RESTORES
JAMS AND FIELDS THEY'RE GETTING
BACK TO THEIR WORKOUTS
CONDITIONING AND THEIR GAMES
BUT THIS IS LEAVING LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND- THEIR KIDS
WITHOUT SPORTS OPTIONS
ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME GIRLS OF
COLOR. THESE ARE GAPS WE MUST
BILL. WHEN THE SAUDIS
AVAILABILITY IS TIGHT AND
COMMUNITY SPORTS GIRLS AND BOYS
TEAMS AND LEAGUES ALIKE SHOULD
GET COMPLETELY EQUITABLE ACCESS
AND PRIORITY. IN ADDITION A
RECENT SURVEY BY THE ASPEN
INSTITUTE'S PROJECT PLAY
EMPHASIZE THE DISCREPANCIES
BETWEEN GIRLS AND BOYS SPORTS
IN THE PANDEMIC ERA. FOR
EXAMPLE BASEBALL PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE PREDOMINANTLY BOYS. ON
AVERAGE LOST JUST FOUR WEEKS OF
ENGAGEMENT DURING KOBE NINETEEN
TIMES WHERE'S GIRLS SOFTBALL
PARTICIPANTS LAS JUST ACTUALLY
SEVEN HOURS EACH WEEK NEARLY
DOUBLE THE TIME LOST. THEN FOR
OVERALL ATHLETES VIRTUAL
TRAINING INCREASED FOR MALES
BUT NOT FOR FEMALE ATHLETES IN
TERMS OF RITUAL OPPORTUNITIES.
WE WOULDN'T ALLOW BOYS TO GAIN
ACCESS TO RE OPEN PLAYGROUNDS
EARLIER ON THAN GIRLS AS
COMMUNITIES OPEN UP. OR TELL
BOYS THAT THEY CAN HAVE MORE
ENGLISH AND MATH CLASSES AT
BETTER TIMES IN THE DAY AS
ENCRYPTING SCHOOLING REOPENS.
LIKEWISE WE SHOULD NOT ALLOW
GENDER INEQUITY IN ANY FORM
WHILE WE'RE RE OPENING YOUTH
SPORTS. LOOKING AGAIN AT SCHOOL
ISSUES AND ONE CAT CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL A PARENT WAS
EXCITED TO HEAR HER DAUGHTER
SPRING SPORT WAS FINALLY COMING.
BACK HOWEVER THE PARENT EXPE
WHEN FOR DA IMMEDIATELY FELL TO
SOME. BECAUSE FOOTBALL. WAS
GIVEN AN EXTRATO BE REACH
THEIR DOES- TEAR AND FOOTBALL
WAS GIVEN THEIR FIRST CHOICE OF
PRACTICE TIMES IN GAME DAYS
WITH THE REMAINDER SPLIT
BETWEEN MULTIPLE SPORTS.
ANOTHER PARENT ADDED I KNOW
THAT THESE ARE UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES BUT AFTER FIFTY YEARS OF
TITLE NINE I WOULD HOPE THAT
THERE WOULD BE EQUITY AND JUST
PLAIN FAIRNESS WHEN RE OPENING
CALIFORNIA SPORTS. IT ALMOST
FEELS AS IF ADMINISTRATOR
THERE'S THINK THAT THEY CAN GET
AWAY WITH THE SCREAMING NATION
BECAUSE THESE ARE UNUSUAL
TIMES. IN YET ANOTHER
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL A SENIOR
GIRL ATHLETE IS STRUGGLING TO
GET A COMPRESSED SPRING SEASON
FOR HER OUTDOOR SPORT. WARDING
WITH ALL ALL THE PRESSURE OF
LIFE AS A YOUNG ADULT MY
SUPPORT IS MY CALM AND
COMFORTABLE PLACE. I SUFFER
FROM ADHD AND PLAYING SPORTS
HELPS ME KEEP MY WORLD IN
ORDER. NOT HAVING THAT RIGHT TO
PLAY IS SO DIFFICULT BUT SEEING
EVERYONE ELSE HAVE THAT RIGHT
AROUND THE IS DEVASTATING. THE
GIRLS ONE OF THE COURTS JUST AS
MUCH AS BOYS THEY WANT TO BUY
FOR THOSE LIFE CHANGING COLLEGE
ATHLETIC SCHOLARSHIPS AND THEY
NEED THAT ATHLETIC OUTLET OF
SPORTS JUST AS MUCH AS BOYS DO.
ALL YOU THIRDS PARENTING
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF STRESS
ANXIETY ISOLATION AND MENTAL
HEALTH STRAINS BROUGHT ABOUT BY
SHUTTERED SCHOOLS AND PROGRAMS
WERE ALSO AWARE THAT THE LET
THEM PLAY CAMPAIGN AND RELATED
LAWSUIT ENDED IN A RECENT COURT
ORDER AND SETTLEMENT ALLOWING
YOUTH SPORTS TO RESUME IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. AS LONG AS
RELEVANT SCHOOL SPORTS FOLLOW
THE SAME OR SIMILAR COVERT
NINETEEN PROTOCOLS IMPOSED FOR
COMPETITION AND PROFESSIONAL OR
COLLEGIATE SPORTS WITH BEEN THE
COUNTY. FURTHER SETTING
STANDARDS ACROSS THE STATE. WE
ARE GLAD THAT SPORTS ARE RE
OPENING SO LONG AS IT'S DONE
SAFELY AND EQUITABLY WE REMIND
ALL INVOLVED WE MUST NOT ONLY
FOLLOW THE NEW COVENANT AND
TEAM PROTOCOLS. BUT ALSO THE
LONGSTANDING TITLE NINE
PROTOCOLS AND SIMILAR STATE
LAWS IMPOSE FOR NEARLY FIVE
DECADES TO ENSURE A GENDER
EQUITABLE REINTRODUCTION OF
SPORT. QUICKLY I'LL TURN TO
HIGHER EDUCATION OUR COLLEAGUES
THAT HELP YOUNG WOMEN COMBAT
GENDER INEQUITY AT THE COLLEGE
AND UNIVERSITY LEVEL REPORT
GENDER INEQUITY IN SPORTS
REOPENING. FOR EXAMPLE I WANT
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITY. WHEN
POTENTIAL COVERED NINETEEN
EXPOSURE WAS DETECTED WITHIN
THE FOOTBALL THE MEN'S FOOTBALL
PROGRAM THE TEAM WAS
QUARANTINED PROVIDED HOUSING
AND BROUGHT EXPENSE MEALS WHEN
POTENTIAL COVERT NINETEEN X.
BOOK ORDER WAS DETECTED WITHIN
A WOMEN'S TEAM AT THE SAME
UNIVERSITY. NO SUCH HOUSING OR
MEAL ARRANGEMENT WAS MADE FOR
THEM A TROUBLING REFLECTION OF
BLATANT UNACCEPTABLE GENDER
EQUALITY INEQUALITY AND SPORTS-
WOMEN'S ATHLETIC PROGRAMS AT
THE COLLEGE LEVEL HAVE BEEN
CUT. OR THREATENED TO BE CUT
WITHOUT HEAT FOR WOMEN ALREADY
LACKING OPPORTUNITY AND TITLE
NINE STANDARDS. COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HAVE TO ENSURE
WOMEN ARE GETTING A
PROPORTIONAL SHARE ABOUT
POLITIC OPPORTUNITIES AND
EQUITY IN TREATMENT AND
BENEFITS REGARDLESS OF THE
PANDEMIC WERE FOR BUDGET
STRAINS. FINALLY LET ME JUST
SAY TO ENSURE GENDER EQUITY
DURING. THE SPORTS RE OPENING
PHASES IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT
TO DO THE FOLLOW THINGS. FIRST
THERE HAS BEEN NO. OF THE ROCK
CHEN EQUITY. DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE MUST REMEMBER THAT.
LAWS LIKE TITLE NINE FOR
SCHOOLS AND AB TWO FOUR FOUR
FOR PARKS AND RECREATION ARE
STILL 1100% IN AFFECT. ALSO
THERE'S NO EXCEPTION OR CARVE
OUT FOR FOOTBALL OR OTHER BOYS
AND MEN'S SPORTS IN TITLE NINE
OR AB TWO FOUR FOUR. SO ALL
SPORTS SHOULD BE GETTING BACK
TO PLAY ON THE STATE LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD IN TERMS OF
SEASON LENGTH. FACILITIES
ACCESS PRACTICE AVAILABILITY
COACHING EQUIPMENT AND MORE
SECOND RE OPENING SHOULD BE A
RESET OPPORTUNITY FOR GENDER
EQUITY IT'S ESSENTIAL TO TRAIN
EVERYONE ON LAWS LIKE TITLE
NINE IN AB TWO FOUR FOUR FOUR.
FAIR PLAY IRLS IN SPORTS AND
OUR NONPROFIT PARTNERS HAVE A
LOT OF GREAT ONLINE TOOL KITS
ON OUR WEBSITE SO THAT
COMMUNITIES CAN GET STARTED
ASSESSING AND INSTILLING GENDER
EQUITY TODAY. AND THEN FINALLY
IF THE SCHOOL OUR COMMUNITY
LEAGUE ISN'T GENDER EQUITABLE
WHEN YOU'RE REAL OPENING YOUR
ATHLETICS DEMAND EXPECT PERSIST
WITH NECESSARY CHANGE. FOR
THOSE IN LEADERSHIP PROACTIVELY
EXAMINE AND ADDRESS ISSUES IS
WHERE YOUR INSTITUTIONS SCHOOLS
PARKS AND REC AND THIRD PARTY
LEAGUES ARE BEING GENDER
INEQUITABLE FOR KEEPING ANY
MEMBERS SUCH AS STUDENTS AND
PARENTS IF YOU SEE GENDER
INEQUITY IN YOUTH SPORTS IN
SCHOOL OR COMMUNITY WEEKS.
CONTACT LOCAL LEADERSHIP NOTIFY
THE COMPANY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF. EDUCATION THE
CALIFORNIA INTERSCHOLASTIC
WRITTEN IN FAIR PLAY FOR GIRLS
IN SPORTS YOU CAN HIGHLIGHT AND
STAMP OUT SB GENDER INEQUITY IN
YOUTH SPORTS THERE ARE MANY
EASY. REASONABLE SOLUTIONS TO
INSTRUCT US AND LET US TODAY
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A TRULY LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD FOR GIRLS ONCE
AND FOR ALL. THANKS SO MUCH FOR
EVERYONE'S TIME AND FOR THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS NOW. ABOUT THE
ISSUES AND WE'RE GRATEFUL. FOR
THIS THE SPECIAL HEARING TODAY.
THANK YOU CAME TO. AND PLAY
GIRLS IN STE. WE CERTAINLY AND
I WILL AS A CHAIR I WANT TO
INTO RE ENTRY THAT. AS WE LOOK
TOWARDS RE OPENING EQUITIES
IMPORTANT- AND IT'S NOT ONLY
IMPORTANT BUT IT'S A CENTRAL-
FOR OUR OUR GIRLS YOUNG GIRLS.
TO BE ABLE TO PERFORM AND PLAY
AS THEIR MALE PEERS UP WITH
THAT THANK YOU THAT WAS OUR
FIRST PANEL WE ARE NOW GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO OUR SECOND
PANEL AGAIN EACH SPEAKER WILL
HAVE FIVE MINUTES OR LESS AND-
I REALLY WANT TO HAVE TO
CUT ANYBODY OFF SO PLEASE STICK
TO YOUR TIME OUR NEXT POINT
PANEL IS PLANS FOR SAY FREE
OPENING. SECONDARY AND POST
SECONDARY ATHLETICS- I WOULD
JUST ASK IF THERE ARE ANY-
INFORMATION THAT YOU MIGHT ADD
REGARDING TO THE FAIR PLAY FOR
GIRLS IN SPORTS AS FAR AS THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE ABOUT
IN EQUITIES THAT WOULD BE. VERY
HELPFUL BUT OUR FIRST PANELIST
WILL BE- THE CHIEF OF STAFF. AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ATHLETICS AND THAT
WOULD BE BRANDON SOSA. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY IN ADDITION TO MY
POSITION AS CHIEF OF STAFF I'VE
ALSO SERVED AS THE CHAIR OF THE
USC ATHLETICS KOBE NINETEEN
ACTION TEAM A ROLE WHICH I'VE
BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR
COORDINATING OUR DEPARTMENTAL
RESPONSE OF THE PANDEMIC TO
PROVIDE A QUICK BACKGROUND ON
USC ATHLETICS WERE A MEMBER OF
THE PAC TWELVE CONFERENCE AND
WE OPERATE TWENTY ONE SPORT-PROGRAMS TWELVE WOMEN'S AND
NINE MEN'S. WITH NEARLY SIX
HUNDRED STUDENT ATHLETES AND
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY COACHES
AND STAFF IN JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
WE PUBLICLY ANNOUNCED THE FIRST
THREE PHASES OF OUR ATHLETICS
RESTART AND RETURN TO CAMPUS
PLAN WITH THREE MEN'S SPORTS IN
THREE WOMEN'S SPORTS THE
STUDENT ATHLETE VOICE WAS
INCLUDED IN OUR RETURN PROCESS.
A SURVEY WAS CONDUCTED BY OUR
FACULTY ATHLETIC REPRESENTATIVE
DR ALAN GREENE A VIRTUAL
HOTLINE WAS ESTABLISHED FOR
STUDENT ATHLETES TO PROVIDE
FEEDBACK INDIVIDUAL MEETINGS
WERE HELD WITH SEVERAL STUDENT
ATHLETES. INCLUDING MULTIPLE
VISITS HOSTED BY PRESIDENT
CAROL FULL AND INFORMATION
SESSIONS AND WEBINARS WERE
HOSTED FOR PARENTS AND STUDENT
ATHLETES AMONG OTHER EFFORTS
AND SUFFICE IT TO SAY THAT OUR
ATHLETES ARE VERY EXCITED TO BE
COMPETING AGAIN. OUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTOCOLS WERE
RIGOROUSLY VETTED FOR EFFICACY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH COMPLIANCE
BUYER CAN'T AS MEDICAL TEAM
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
GROUP AND THE OFFICE OF GENERAL
COUNSEL. CENTRAL TO OUR CODE
MITIGATION STRATEGIES HAVE BEEN
OUR TESTING PROTOCOLS WHICH ARE
ALIGNED WITH THE NCAA PAC
TWELVE IN UNIVERSITY GUIDELINES
PRESENTLY STUDENT ATHLETES IN
ALL SPORTS TESTED MINIMUM TWICE
WEEKLY THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY
SURVEILLANCE TESTING PROGRAM
WHICH IS AVAILABLE TO ALL
MEMBERS OF THE CAMPUS COMMUNITY
AND OUR STUDENT ATHLETES IN
HIGH RISK SPORTS UNDERGO DAILY
ANTIGEN TESTING THROUGH A
SERVICE PROVIDED BY THE PAC
TWELVE CONFERENCE IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THEIR POLICIES.
ESSENTIALLY WERE ABLE TO TEST
THOSE ATHLETES PRIOR TO THE
START OF ACTIVITIES EACH DAY TO
INSURE THAT ALL ATHLETES ARE
CLEARED TO PARTICIPATE. GIVEN
THE NATURE OF THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS AND THE SPIRIT OF
TRANSPARENCY EVEN AS A PRIVATE
INSTITUTION WE TYPICALLY
RELEASE ARE CO IN NINETEEN
TESTING RESULTS TO THE MEDIA AT
EVERY MONDAY. OVERALL I CAN SAY
WITH THE UTMOST CERTAINTY THAT
OUR COBIT AVOIDANCE STRATEGIES
WOULD HAVE BEEN FAR LESS
SUCCESSFUL WITHOUT SUCH A
COMPREHENSIVE TESTING PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY WE'VE HAD THE
EXTRAORDINARY OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE WITH STATE AND COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS AS
CALIFORNIA WAS FINALIZING ITS
HIGHER EDUCATION GUIDANCE FOR
COLLEGE ATHLETICS WE WERE
PLEASED TO BE A RESOURCE FOR
THE STATE WERE EXTREMELY
APPRECIATIVE OF LANDET JOSE AND
I'M PERSONALLY GRATEFUL AS WELL
FOR THAT PARTNERSHIP. LOCALLY
WE COLLABORATED WITH L. A.
COUNTY WHICH FEATURED JIM CALLS
CODE AVOIDANCE PLAN REVIEWS
SITE WALK THROUGHS AND VISITS
DURING LIVE EVENTS MOST
RECENTLY WE WERE PROUD TO SHARE
OUR PROTOCOLS AND BEST
PRACTICES WITH THE NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION TO ASSIST WITH
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS
PLANNING WE'RE THRILLED THAT
OUR LEARNINGS AND EXPERIENCES
MAY HAVE EVEN BEEN THE SMALLEST
BIT HELPFUL WHILE IT MAY TAKE
YEARS TO DEFINITIVELY ANSWER
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT
STUDENT ATHLETES ARE SAFER IN A
STRUCTURED ENVIRONMENT. IF OR
INDEED EVER ABLE TO DO SO AT
ALL WE'VE IDENTIFIED A FEW
EMERGING THEMES TO OF WHICH
I'LL HIGHLIGHT TODAY THE FIRST
RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH WHICH
HAS BEEN REFERENCE DOCTOR ROBIN
SCHOFIELD OVERSEAS ARE SPORTS
PSYCHOLOGY PROGRAM WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS THE LARGEST IN
COLLEGE ATHLETICS AND IS GROW
BY THREE POSITIONS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENT ATHLETES DR
SCHOFIELD SHARED THE FOLLOWING
SUMMARY OF HER ANALYSIS. FOR
THE STUDENT ATHLETE NOT BEING
ABLE TO PRACTICE AND COMPETE AS
EXPERIENCED AS BEING REMOVED
FROM A LIFELONG PURPOSE ONLY
WORSE TEENS AND YOUNG ADULTS
HAVE YET TO EXPAND AND DEEPEN
THEIR IDENTITIES AND OTHER
AREAS OF LIFE WHICH WOULD
OTHERWISE FORTIFY THEM DURING
TROUBLING TIMES MOST ATHLETES
DON'T EVEN REMEMBER THEIR LIVES
BEFORE SUPPORT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THAT
EMOTIONAL DISTURBANCES IN ONE
AREA OF LIFE CAN AFFECT
MOTIVATION AND OTHER AREAS
INCREASES IN DEPRESSION AND
ANXIETY AS WELL AS GENERAL
REDUCTIONS IN WELL BEING HAVE
SPILLED OVER TO AFFECT
MOTIVATION IN ACADEMICS IN
OTHER AREAS OF FUNCTIONING. THE
SECOND TEAM IS IN REGARD TO OUR
LEARNINGS ABOUT STUDENT ATHLETE
COMPLIANCE WITH CODE PROTOCOLS
WHEN THE PAC TWELVE VOTED TO
RESUME ATHLETICS ACTIVITIES ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY AFTER PREVIOUSLY PAUSING
WE EXPERIENCED. SEVENTEEN DAYS
WITHOUT ANY POSITIVE CASES THE
LONGEST STRETCH WE'VE HAD
WITHOUT ANY POSITIVE CASES
AMONG OUR STUDENT ATHLETE
POPULATION. SINCE WE BEGAN
TESTING REGULARLY IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY. TODAY OUR CAMPUS
MEDICAL TEAM HAS NOT IDENTIFIED
A SINGLE POSITIVE CASE THAT HAS
BEEN TRACED ATHLETICS
ACTIVITIES. SO WE CERTAINLY
ACKNOWLEDGE IT IS POSSIBLE SUCH
TRANSMISSION HAS OCCURRED. UPON
OUR RETURN TO CAMPUS AFTER THE
WINTER BREAK WITHIN THE FIRST
THREE WEEKS OF THE JANUARY
REENTRY PROCESS WE WERE
MANAGING SEVENTY ONE STUDENT
ATHLETES IN COVERT PROTOCOLS.
EITHER FROM A POSITIVE TEST OR
FOR THE MOST PART ATHLETES WHO
WERE QUARANTINED DUE TO CONTACT
TRACING. BY THE FIRST WEEK IN
MARCH WITH STUDENT ATHLETES
FULLY IMMERSED IN THEIR
ACTIVITIES THAT NUMBER HAD BEEN
REDUCED TO ZERO. FINALLY I JUST
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANK OUR COACHES AND STAFF FOR
THEIR SERVICE TO OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES. AT USC ATHLETICS
WE'VE DEFINED OUR VISION TO BE
THE MOST STUDENT ATHLETE CENTER
PROGRAM IN THE COUNTRY. AND
THAT PURPOSES REALLY MANIFEST
ITSELF IN MANY INSPIRING WAYS
OVER THE PAST YEAR. AS AN
ATHLETICS ADMINISTRATOR I CAN
TELL YOU THERE'S NOTHING MORE
DEVASTATING THAN THE FEELING
YOU EXPERIENCE WHEN YOU CAN'T
DELIVER FOR YOUR ATHLETES. AND
THAT'S BEEN THE DRIVING FORCE
OF OUR RELENTLESSNESS IN THE
FACE OF SUCH UTTER EXHAUSTION.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AND A U. S. B. F. X. IS
HAPPY TO BE A RESOURCE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE. MOVING FORWARD
ANYWAY THAT WE CAN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BRANDON SOSA FROM
USC. WILL GO HEAD AND TAKE OUR
PANELISTS AND THEN ALL OPEN IT
UP TO QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS.
AND NEXT WE HAVE DIRECTOR OF
ATHLETICS FROM CAL STATE.
UNIVERSITY BAKERSFIELD DR
KENNETH SINGH FRIED. YES THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE- I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU HAVING ME TODAY MY NAME IS-
KENNETH ZIGGY SIEGFRIED I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF ATHLETICS AT CSU
BAKERSFIELD. AND FOR THOSE THAT
DO NOT KNOW WHO SHE IS SHE BE
PARTICIPATES IN NCAA DIVISION
ONE ATHLETICS AS A MEMBER OF
THE BIG WEST CONFERENCE- SO WE
SPONSOR TEN. FEMALE SPORTS IN
SIX MALE SPORTS- THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC AND THANKS TO MANY- WE
HAVE FOUND A LOT OF SUCCESS IN
OUR SAFETY PROTOCOLS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AT CSUB.
SO TODAY I'LL FOCUS MY COMMENTS
AROUND. GENDER EQUITY WHICH I
KNOWS BEEN DISCUSSED- IN THE
FIRST ANALYST- BEST PRACTICES
THAT HAVE ALLOWED US TO
SUCCESSFULLY. RETURN OUR
ATHLETIC PROGRAMS TO TRAINING
AND COMPETITION AND THAT ALSO
SHARE MY PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT IS
IN THE BEST INTEREST- FOR OUR
STUDENT ATHLETES. AND I DO
BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND ON THE FRONT END FOR
EVERYONE WHAT THE ROLE IS OF
THE NCAA. THE NCAA HAS FOCUSED
ITS ATTENTION TO PROVIDING
GUIDANCE SO NOT REQUIREMENTS-
AND THEY'VE ALSO PROVIDED
LEGISLATIVE RELIEF TO ROLES-
BETTER HELP THEIR MEMBER
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS- THOSE
STUDENT ATHLETES WHO DO NOT
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE
OR THOSE THAT EVEN COMPETED. IN
THE FALL AND WINTER GOT AN
EXTRA YEAR OF ELIGIBILITY. SO
THE NCAA HAS PROVIDED.
REQUIREMENTS ONLY AROUND NCAA
CHAMPIONSHIPS. WHICH IS WHAT
THEY MANAGE- SO SORT OF LIKE
MARCH MADNESS- THE WRESTLING
CHAMPIONSHIPS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT THEY HAVE NOT PROVIDED-
MANDATORY REQUIREMENTS AROUND
REGULAR SEASON COMPETITION. SO
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE GENDER
EQUITY ONE CRITICAL AREA ARE
ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL AREAS
AROUND THE OPENING IS GENDER
EQUITY AND I CAN TELL YOU THE
FOCUS OF MY DISSERTATION-
RESEARCH WAS AROUND GENDER
EQUITY AND FEMALE STUDENT
ATHLETES SATISFACTION SO IT'S-
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT I AM-
PASSION ABOUT AND I'LL- DONE
SOME RESEARCH ON- IT WAS
PREVIOUSLY STATED BUT I'LL
REEMPHASIZE A LOT OF THE
ATTENTION SPECIFICALLY MEDIA
ATTENTION. HAS FOCUSED ON RE
OPENING OF FOOTBALL AND MEN'S
BASKETBALL- BUT I BELIEVE IT'S
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO KNOW
THAT THE NCAA SPONSORS THIRTY
EIGHT OTHER SPORTS WITH. TWENTY
ONE OF THOSE BEING FEMALE
SPORTS SO I BELIEVE IT'S
CRITICAL FOR LEADERS TO FOCUS
ON THE WELL BEING OF ALL
STUDENT ATHLETES. NOT JUST
THOSE THAT ARE OFTEN IN THE
MEDIA SPOTLIGHT. AND I DIDN'T
WANT TO GO OVER A FEW BEST
PRACTICES THAT I FEEL ARE
IMPORTANT ON GENDER EQUITY- ONE
IS MAKING SURE WHEN DECISIONS
ARE BEING MADE. THAT THERE'S
DIVERSITY IN QUITE SO SIMILAR
TO BRANDON AT USC WE HAVE AN
ATHLETICS COACH IN NINETEEN
ACTION TEAM WITH A WIDE VARIETY
OF MEMBERS THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
DECISIONS AND DISCUSSIONS.
INCLUDING MALE AND FEMALE
STUDENT ATHLETES ARE SENIOR
WOMAN ADMINISTRATOR- AND MANY
OTHERS. I BELIEVE THERE'S ALSO
WHILE THIS ISN'T THE ONLY PART
OF TITLE NINE. I BELIEVE- IT'S
CRITICAL THAT PEOPLE LOOK AT
PARTICIPATION NUMBERS SO IF THE
PARTICIPATION NUMBERS AND AGAIN
IT'S A FEDERAL LAW. SHOULD
MATCH CLOSELY TO THE OVERALL
STUDENT POPULATION FOR INSTANCE
AT CSUB WE HAVE 61% OF OUR
GENERAL STUDENTS THAT ARE
FEMALE. SO WE LOOK TO MIMIC
THOSE PARTICIPATION NUMBERS
WITH OUR STUDENT ATHLETES YOU
TOO ARE COMING BACK TO CAMPUS
COMMUNICATION IS CRITICAL AND I
KNOW THAT COULD BE EMPHASIZED-
OVER AND OVER ADVOCACY WE NEED
MORE PEOPLE JUST LIKE WITH THE
FAIR PLAY FOR GIRLS IN SPORTS.
WE NEED MORE PEOPLE TO SPEAK UP
TO ADDRESS INEQUITIES WHEN THEY
SEE. THE OTHER THING I WANTED
TO COVER IS- KEY INGREDIENTS TO
SUCCESS IN GETTING ATHLETICS
PROGRAMS BACK I DO BELIEVE
THERE ARE SOME CRITICAL AREAS
THEY'RE- SIMILAR TO BRANDON'S
EXPERIENCE AT USC. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
MAJORITY OF CODE NINETEEN CASES
WE SAW. HAVE BEEN RELATED TO
ALL CAMPUS ACTIVITIES NOT ON
CAMPUS ACTIVITIES. WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO TRACE ANYTHING
BACK TO. BOB ATTENTION OR
PRACTICES- AND THEN BRIEFLY THE
THREE KEY INGREDIENTS- THAT WE
HAVE FOUND TO BE SUCCESSFUL
CREATING A BUBBLE IS CLOSE TO
ABOUT WAS POSSIBLE. HAVING
FRANK CONVERSATIONS WITH
STUDENT ATHLETES- PUTTING IN
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES- AND
LASTLY I'LL JUST SAY THAT I
FEEL STRONGLY THAT IT'S IN THE
BEST INTERESTS. OF OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES TO ALLOW THEM TO
RETURN TO COMPETING IN SPORTS I
BELIEVE IT'S WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH AND OVERALL
WELL BEING AND IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
REMEMBER THAT ATHLETICS
PROVIDES GREAT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENT ATHLETES FOR
EXPERIENCE ALL LEARNING. SO I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT STUDENT
ATHLETES ARE SAFER ON CAMPUS
AND OFF CAMPUS I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT OUT THERE TALKING
TO THOSE ATHLETES AND HEARING
THEIR STORIES. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE HAVE A WHO IS THE INTERIM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA CAN MEET COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ATHLETIC ASSOCIATION
JENNIFER CARD DOWN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME- FIRST OFF I'D LIKE TO-
THANK DOCTOR ONE DAY JUST
SITTING ON BEHALF OF OUR
HUNDRED AND TEN INSTITUTIONS
FOR HER RESPONSIVENESS TO OUR
MANY REQUESTS FOR INFORMATION
CLARIFICATION AND DIRECTION AS
IT RELATES TO THE I. H. I. HV
GUIDANCE- I SHUDDER TO THINK
WHERE WE WOULD BE WITHOUT HER
SENSIBILITY OUR INITIAL
CONTACT- TOOK ANOTHER JOB AND
WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT AND IT WAS
A DEAD SILENCE FOR MONTHS UNTIL
SHE PICKED UP THE PHONE. AND
CAME TO OUR RESCUE SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH DR JOSEPH- WE'RE A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN THE
THAN THE FIRST TWO SPEAKERS AND
THAT THERE ARE THERE ON CAMPUS-
THE THREE C. TWO A. OVERSEAS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ATHLETICS
WOULD LIKE I SAID FOUR HUNDRED
AND TEN INSTITUTIONS. WE
SPONSOR TWENTY FOUR SPORTS
TWELVE FOR MEN TWELVE FOR
WOMEN. NOW WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE
CHAMPIONSHIPS THAT WE OVERSEE.
WE PROVIDED A FRAMEWORK- FOR
OUR MEMBER INSTITUTIONS- THAT'S
REALLY OUR RESPONSIBILITY IS TO
PROVIDE A FRAMEWORK- TAKE THE
INFORMATION FROM THE IT
GUIDANCE. EXPLAINED THAT TO
THEN WORK WITH THEM- HAVE THEM.
OBVIOUSLY KEEP IN TOUCH
IMMENSELY WITH THEIR HOUSE
THEIR COUNTY AND THEIR
DISTRICT. GET THEIR PLANS
APPROVED THINGS OF THAT NATURE
SO- WE'RE WE'RE COMING I'M
COMING OUT DIFFERENTLY THAN-
THAN- THE TWO PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
SO I JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT A
FEW DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE-
NCAA AND THE THREE C. TO ACT.
AND THE REASON IS THAT I GET A
LOT OF QUESTIONS AS TO WHY
WE'RE NOT PLAYING WHY AREN'T WE
ARE NOT THERE YET AND WE ARE WE
WERE STARTING TO NOT COVER THAT
IN A SECOND- BUT THERE'S THERE
ARE SOME. FOUNDATIONAL
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE THREE
C. TWO A. AND THE NCAA AND THEN
OUR INSTITUTIONS AND THEIR
INSTITUTIONS- I ALWAYS LIKE TO
SAY THAT THE THREE SEE TO IT IS
LIKE THE NCAA. BUT WITHOUT THE
MONEY WITH THE STAFF THERE ARE
SIX POSITIONS WERE CURRENTLY
HAVE FOUR FILLED- AND WE JUST
DON'T HAVE THE BUDGET- THAT
THAT THE NCAA DOES TO BE ABLE
TO PRODUCE ON THE LEVEL THAT
THEY DO. OUR INSTITUTIONS
DIFFER OUR MOST OF OUR NCAA
COUNTERPARTS- BECAUSE WE MUST
TAKE FROM EXISTING RESOURCES TO
PAY FOR ATHLETICS WE DON'T
HAVE. LARGE GATES WE DON'T HAVE
TELEVISION CONTRACTS. WE DON'T
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE. WE
HAVE A VERY SMALL STABS THE FEW
THAT DO MAYBE HAVE AN ASSISTANT
OR ASSOCIATE ATHLETIC DIRECTOR
MAYBE ONE OR TWO- THERE'S JUST
NOT A LOT OF LOT OF BODIES
GOING AROUND- AND ALSO OUR- WE
DON'T HAVE- WE ALREADY STRUGGLE
WITH. ENOUGH THAT'S WHY
TRAINERS WE HAVE A TRAINER WE
JUST TRY WITH HAVING ENOUGH OF
THEM AND THE PANDEMIC MADE OF
WORSE- BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
WIND RESPONSE OF. ABOUT AROUND
TESTING THE CLAY PRODUCTS AND
ALL. IT FALLS ON THEIR
SHOULDERS- AND SO. THAT'S
THAT'S JUST A PART OF WHAT WE
DEAL WITH EVERY DAY IN THE
OTHER PART OF THAT JOB. THAT
WAS MENTIONED IS NOT POSSIBLE
BEHIND. THEIR UNREALISTIC FOR
US BECAUSE ONLY TWELVE OUR
INSTITUTIONS HAVE DORMS- AND SO
WE HAVE A VERY. TRANSIENT IF
YOU WILL COMMUNITY- BECAUSE
WAIT WHERE THEY'RE COMING IN
FROM FROM ALL DIFFERENT PLACES
AROUND. SO I MENTIONED THE
PROCESS WHERE THEY WOULD SPEAK
ABOUT THE PROCESS AND BASICALLY
THE THREE SEED TO A FORM TO
COVER NINETEEN WORKING GROUP
JUST LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE
GENERALLY IN THE PANDEMIC. AND
THIS GROUP HAS BEEN RESPONSIBLE
FOR ALL RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
PRESENTED TO AND APPROVED BY
OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS- THE
RECOMMENDATIONS RANGE FROM
MODIFICATIONS TO PLAYING A
PRACTICE SEASONS ELIGIBILITY IN
RECRUITING ROLES. AND APPROVING
PLANS CREATED BY THOSE ATHLETIC
TRAINERS AS IT RELATES TO
TESTING STUDENT ATHLETES
COACHES STAFF AND OFFICIALS.
FROM THE PLANS ARE WHAT WE ARE
THE PLANS THAT WE ARE FOLLOWING
TODAY ARE THE DIRECT RESULT OF
THIS GROUP'S WORK AND THIS
GROUP CONTINUES TO MEET WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO UNTIL THINGS
ARE BACK TO NORMAL- WE DO HAVE
FISCAL CONCERNS- BUT BEFORE I
GO THERE. STATUS RIGHT NOW WE
ARE FALL SPORTS WE MOVED OUR
FALL SPORTS TO THIS FIRST HALF
OF THE SPRING OR SPRING SPORTS
THE PUSH THEM BACK TO THE
SECOND HALF OF THE SPRING. WE
HAVE THIRTY TWO INSTITUTIONS
AND A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
TEAMS THAT ABOUT SAID THEY
INTEND TO PRACTICE AND COMPETE
BETWEEN JANUARY EIGHTEENTH AND
APRIL SEVENTEENTH. THAT'S
ABOUT- SIXTEEN PER. OF WHAT WE
NORMALLY WOULD HAVE. AND THEN
FOR THE PRING WE HAVE SIXTY
FIVE PROGRAMS AND THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR SO FAR- THEY'RE OUT
THEY'RE ABLE TO EITHER CHANGE
THE CHANGE THEY'RE ABLE TO
CHANGE HER MIND OPT IN OPT OUT-
BASED ON CIRCUMSTANCES- AND
THAT'S- ABOUT 60% OF OUR TEAMS.
AND ROUGHLY GENERAC WE WISE
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE SAME AS WHAT
WE NORMALLY HAVE- SO THAT. MEN
AND WOMEN WERE PROGRAMS- IN SO
THEY CAN- PRACTICE INTERVIEW
BETWEEN MARCH TWENTY SEVENTH
AND JUNE TWENTY THIRD. THEY ARE
ONLY ABLE TO DO 70% OF THEIR
SEASON- SO. A FORTY GAME
BASEBALL SEASON WOULD BE
REDUCED 270% AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY WOULD BE ALLOWED TO DO-
WORSE AT THE HANDS. FORTY GAMES
SOFTBALL SEASON FOR THAT MATTER
I DON'T EXPECT ANYTHING TOO
MANY TO HIT THAT NUMBER
BECAUSE- OF THE COST OF TESTING
INCLUDING. PROTOCOLS COUNTY OR
DISTRICT RESTRICTIONS ON
OPPONENTS LOCATED OUTSIDE OF
EITHER FACULTY CONTRACT ISSUES
IN THE GENERAL LACK OF
AVAILABILITY OF COMPETITION-
AND IT KIND OF TIES INTO THE
COSTS. OF THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH- THE COST OF TESTING IS A
MAX AS WELL AS THE ENHANCED.
PROTOCOLS TO TRAVEL THE EXTRA
STAFFING- IN ORDER FOR OUR
ATHLETIC. OPPORTUNITIES ARE
TIED TO CLASS SARKAAL. ARE
CONCERNED WITH OPENING. THEIR
COLLEGES TO PROVIDE. RESOURCES
TO THEIR STUDENTS. THERE ARE
OUT THERE ALSO- CONCENTRATING
UP OPENING UP CLASSES
DELIVERING THOSE CLASSES
HOPEFULLY BACK- IN PERSON AT
SOME POINT. AND SO I THOUGHT
EXES IS JUST. PART OF THAT
EQUATION IS NOT SEPARATE FROM
THE AND FINALLY THE THREE C. TO
A BELIEVES THAT DUE TO THE
ROLLOUT OF VACCINATIONS IN
COMBAT COMMON NINETEEN NUMBERS
GOING DOWN. THE TIME IS RIGHT
TO LOOK AT REVISIONS TO THE
ICICI GUIDANCE THAT WILL ALLOW
THREE C. TOO MANY INSTITUTIONS
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
STUDENT ATHLETES WE SERVE THE
CHANCE TO GET BACK ON THE FIELD
COURT AND TRACK IN THE FALL.
ATHLETICS'S INTERCULTURAL
ENROLLMENT AND COMPLETION OF
OUR FOR OUR POPULATION WHICH IS
MORE THAN 70% OF OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES ARE FROM
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
GROUPS. WE HAVE LOST DO NOT
PLEASE DO THE ABSENCE OF
ATHLETIC PRACTICING COMPETITION
SIMPLY PUT ATHLETICS IS
ESSENTIAL TO OUR STUDENTS
SUCCESS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH- SOME DISMAL OUTCOMES
THAT WE'RE HEARING AND WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO GET PEOPLE
BACK AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
SOME OF IT WILL BE RECTIFIED BY
THEM ACTUALLY PARTICIPATING IN
SPORTS ALL RIGHT AT THE FINISH
OFF THIS PANEL WE HAVE RHONDA'S
SAID THE WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION-
WELCOME RON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
AND I BELIEVE YOUR HOST WAS
GOING TO GIVE ME THE ABILITY TO
SHARE MY SCREEN- BECAUSE I DID
WANT TO SHOW YOU A FEW- THERE
WE GO. YEAH PERFECT. OKAY SO
THANK YOU AGAIN I APPRECIATE
THE PPORTUNITY TO- TO BE HERE
WITH YOU TODAY AND- TO DISCUSS
THE VERY IMPORTANT ASPECT OF
HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS AND THE
RETURN TO HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS AS
MANY OF THE PANELISTS OF
MENTIONED- WE ALL HAVE
INVOLVEMENT EITHER WITH SELF
FOR FAMILY- ALSO I'LL CHOOSE TO
FOCUS MALES IN MY FAMILY MY
WIFE WAS A COLLEGIATE ATHLETE I
HAVE THREE DAUGHTERS- TO HAVE
PLAYED HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS
INDIVIDUAL IN COLLEGE SPORTS
AND I AM A CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL
SENIOR WATER POLO PLAYER AND
SWIMMER WHO IS VERY EXCITED TO
BE BACK IN THE POOL AND- SHE'S
OFF TO PLAY COLLEGE WATER POLO
NEXT YEAR AND THEN I HAVE A SON
WHO'S A HIGH SCHOOL A- STUDENT
ATHLETE AND FRESHMAN. ALL OF US
IN THE STATE OFFICE- I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS AND RETURN
TO MANY OF US AS I MENTIONED
HAVE CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT ATHLETES THAT ARE
LOOKING TO GET BACK TO
PARTICIPATE QUICK OVERVIEW THE
CIF AS YOU KNOW WHERE THE
GOVERNING BODY OF HIGH SCHOOL
ATHLETICS WE HAVE SIXTEEN
HUNDRED FIVE MEMBER SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE WITH EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENT
ATHLETES OVER IN OUR THOUSAND
STUDENT ATHLETES AND WE'RE IN
FEDERATION MODEL WITH TEN SEMI
AUTONOMOUS GEOGRAPHIC SECTIONS
AND OUR STATE OFFICE LOCATED
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. PUTTING
THIS IN PERSPECTIVE THE NCAA
ACROSS THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
DIVISION ONE TO BE HAS ELEVEN
OTHER MEMBER INSTITUTIONS AND
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENT ATHLETES SO GIVES YOU
AN IDEA OF THE SIZE AND SCOPE.
OF THE ORGANIZATION THAT WE'RE
ALL VERY PROUD OF. WE DEVELOP
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND- DOCTOR UPON WHO WAS
ON EARLIER HAS BEEN A BIG PART
OF THAT WERE VERY APPRECIATIVE.
OF THOSE PARTNERSHIPS. ALONG
THE WAY WE MADE MANY
ADJUSTMENTS- WE'VE ADJUSTED OUR
CALENDARS- WE DELAYED THE
BEGINNING OF OUR SPORTS TO
DECEMBER AND THEN HAD TO
FURTHER PUSH IT BACK. BECAUSE I
WANTED OUR SCHOOLS GOAL TO
FOCUS FIRST ON HOW THEY WERE
GOING TO TURN THEIR STUDENTS TO
LEARNING AND ACADEMICS. AND THE
TIME NEEDED TO DO THAT AND
IMPROVE THEIR DISTANCE LEARNING
WHICH WHICH THEY'VE OBVIOUSLY
DONE. WE ALSO MADE ADJUSTMENTS
TO CHAMPIONSHIP EVENTS. SO THAT
WE PUT ASIDE A LOT OF OUR FANS
OUR CHAMPIONSHIP EVENTS
ESPECIALLY FOR FIRST SEASON. TO
PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
REGULAR SEASON FOR OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES AND OUR MEMBER
SCHOOLS. WE'RE HOPING THAT WE
COULD MAYBE HAVE SOME SPRING
CHAMPIONSHIP EVENTS. IF THE
TRAVEL. RESTRICTIONS ARE AT
LEAST RELAX A LITTLEBIT TO
ALLOW STATEWIDE TRAVEL IN
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE MANY OF OUR
SPRING STUDENT ATHLETES MISTER
STATE FACT ALL OF OUR SPRING
SARGSYAN ATHLETES. MISTER
CHAMPIONSHIP EVENTS LAST
SEASON. WE ALSO ISSUED A LETTER
TO OUR MEMBER SCHOOLS BECAUSE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
OF OUR MEMBER SCHOOLS
UNDERSTOOD THE CIS EXPECTATION
WITH RESPECTED HEARING. TO THE
GUIDANCE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND THAT IS
MEMBERS OF THE ORGANIZATION-
YOU AGREE OH FIVE OUR RULES AND
OUR DECISIONS AND ONE OF THOSE
DECISIONS WAS. TO ABIDE BY ALL
THE SAFETY PRECAUTIONS BEING
PUT OUT THERE BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND I'M REALLY
PROUD OF OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
ADMINISTRATORS FOR HOW THEY
HANDLE THIS BECAUSE FRANKLY
THEY WATCHED A LOT OF
ORGANIZATIONS OUTSIDE OF THE C.
I HAVE. CONTINUE TO PLAY IN AND
MAYBE NEVER EVEN STOPPED. AND
THEY CONTINUE TO HOLD THE LINE
AND UNTIL WE'RE ALLOWED TO
BEGIN MOST RECENTLY- WE STILL
ARE DEALING WITH A LOT OF
ISSUES REGARDING U. SPORTS IN
IG GUIDANCE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
OUR- OUR INDOOR SPORTS ARE NOW
UNDER THE IG GUIDES THEY WANT
TO START WITH VERY DIFFERENT
TESTING PROTOCOLS. AND SO WE'RE
WORKING WITH THEM TO DISCOVER
HOW TO. TO MAXIMIZE THE RETURN.
TO PLAY FOR AS MANY STUDENTS AS
POSSIBLE. WE ARE VERY LUCKY CAL.
ALL TO HAVE A SPORTS MEDICINE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE MADE UP OF
SOME OF THE BEST SPORTS
MEDICINE PHYSICIANS ETCETERA
AND- NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THE WORLD- BECAUSE OF WHERE
WE'RE LOCATED AND THEY'VE
HELPED US DEVELOP MANY OF THE
FOLLOWING RESOURCES- RETURN TO
PLAY ACTIVITIES AND TRAINING.
SO THAT STUDENTS THAT HAVEN'T
PLAYED IN AWHILE ARE PUT BACK
OUT THERE IN THE SAFEST MANNER
POSSIBLE. WE'VE ALSO ISSUED TO
RECENT DOCUMENTS THAT WILL BE
ABUSED OR ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
AND ALSO TO PHYSICIANS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FOR WHEN
THEY BELIEVE STUDENT ATHLETES
NEED TO BE TESTED FOR CARDIAC
EVALUATED AND- CARDIAC TESTING.
AFTER A POSITIVE C TEST CASE.
AND THEN ALSO GRADUATED RETURN
TO PLAY WAS ADDED TO OUR
WEBSITE AS A RECOMMENDATION FOR
OUR SCHOOLS. DEPENDING ON THE
TYPE OF CASE I SAW A
SYMPTOMATIC TO SEVERE. AND HOW
TO BRING STUDENTS BACK AFTER
THE INITIAL TEN DAY QUARANTINE
PERIOD- AND BRING IT BACK
SLOWLY WITH RESPECT TO
EXERCISE. OUR NATIONAL
FEDERATION- WHICH IS KIND OF
LIKE OUR IN CA- IS ISSUED A CAR
SITS FREE FOR COACHES AND
ADMINISTRATORS. WITH RESPECT TO
COPE IN NINETEEN. WE ALSO
INSTITUTED AND THIS GOES TO
SPEAK TO- WHAT YOU HEARD
EARLIER WITH THAT WITH THE FAIR
PLAY- FOR GIRLS IN SPORTS. AND
I DO APPRECIATE THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DEVELOP WITH THAT
ORGANIZATION IS SPECIFICALLY
WITH WITH KIM TURNER- THEY HAVE
CALLED ISSUES TO OUR ATTENTION
BOTH IN PRIOR YEARS IN THIS
YEAR AND IT'S ALLOWED US TO
ADDRESS ISSUES AS THEY OCCUR.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A
FAIR AND EQUITABLE RETURN TO
PLAYING CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THAT'S THE GOAL FOR ALL OF US.
OR SEE I HAVE LEADERSHIP
INITIATIVE. THE GOAL IS TO
DEVELOP FUTURE LEADERS A CIF
AND ONE OF OUR FIRST PROJECTS
THAT WE HAD TO WORK ON WAS. HOW
DO WE DEAL WITH THE ISSUES OF
EQUITY WITH RESPECT TO GENDER
RACE AND ACCESS WHICH WE'RE
SEEING EXACERBATED THIS YEAR.
SO THESE ARE THE INFORMATION
EVERYTHING YOU SEE HERE AS
LINKS AND RESOURCES FOR HOW TO
INCREASE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GIRLS AND SPORTS. NOT JUST FOR
PLAYING SPORTS BUT ALSO A
FUTURE IN SPORTS OUR BELIEF IS
THAT. THE MORE A FEMALE STUDENT
ATHLETES. SEAT WOMEN OUT THERE
THAT ARE COACHING BETTER
TEACHING THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
SPORTS THEY'RE PLAYING SPORTS
OF THE KWIDZYN PROFESSIONAL
LEVELS. BUT THOSE CAN BE THEIR
ROLE MODELS SO THERE'S A LOT OF
RESOURCES HERE THAT WE
DEVELOPED. TO ASSIST IN THAT
RESPECT AND- WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO. AS YOU HEARD NEXT
YEAR'S A FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY
OF TITLE NINE. AND WE INTEND TO
MAKE THAT A MAJOR FOCUS OF OUR
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES AND IN THE
FUTURE. WE ALSO WANT TO LOOK AT
THE ISSUE OF RACE ON OUR
CAMPUSES AND HELP PROVIDE
STRATEGIES FOR COACHES AND
ATHLETIC ATHLETIC
ADMINISTRATORS INSIDE
ADMINISTRATORS TO HELP
INTERRUPTING PRINT NEGATIVE
EXPERIENCES. AND GIVE THEM THE
TOOLS TO DO SO WE THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT WE THAT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE BEING A
RESOURCE FOR OUR MEMBER SCHOOLS.
AND THEN WE ALSO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT ACCESS IN THIS IS BEEN A
MAJOR CONCERN OF OURS. IN THE
RETURN TO PLAY. WE DON'T WANT
TO SEE ONLY THE SCHOOLS THAT
CAN AFFORD TO RETURN TO PLAY
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT CAN
AFFORD TO RETURN TO PLAY TO DO
SO. SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S APPROPRIATE TESTING
RESOURCES FOR EVERYONE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF OUR
KIDS ARE ABLE TO COME BACK. TO
THE FIELD TO PLAY THE POOLS THE
JAMS ETCETERA. AND DO IT IN A
SAFE. SAFE MANNER AS POSSIBLE
AS YOU HEARD EARLIER THERE'S IS
A LOT OF STUDENT ATHLETES THAT
WERE ABLE TO CONTINUE ON CLUB
SPORTS. BUT MANY CAN'T AFFORD
TO DO THAT AND HIGH SCHOOL
SPORTS. IS ONE OF THE FEW AND
MAYBE THE ONLY FREE RESOURCE
LEFT FOR STUDENTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN ATHLETICS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR IT WHEN WE
RETURN. SO I THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR YOUR
IMPORTANT WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND-
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU RON
NECESSITY- A SHORTER WAY TO SAY
IT IS C. I. F. EVERYBODY. KNOWS
WHAT THAT IS WHO'VE PLAYED A-
HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS AND- I
MYSELF- JUST GAIN SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE-
WORKSHOPS YOU'RE HOSTING AND-
OTHERS. ARE NOW IS THE TIME FOR
US IF ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE A
QUESTION WHETHER YOUR ON WEB
ACCESS. OR HERE IN PERSON. FOR
OUR PANELIST. OKAY WE HAVE ONE
FROM OUR VICE CHAIR. OKAY I'M
JUST CURIOUS IF ANYBODY ON THE
PANEL KNOWS ARE THERE OTHER
STATES OPEN FOR SECONDARY AND
POST SECONDARY SPORTS AND WHAT
GUIDELINES HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE
SO AND- ALSO IN REGARDS TO
TESTING DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
HAVE THE CAPACITY AND
RESOURCES- TO TEST. CAN YOU SAY
THAT LAST PART YES BECAUSE I
IDEA DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE
THE CAPACITY AND RESOURCES FOR
TESTING BY. ALL RIGHT THAT WAS
FROM ANYBODY ON THE PANEL NOW
HOW DO WE DO THIS VIRTUALLY IF
WE'RE ASKING THE PANEL. THINK
ABOUT EACH OTHER YES WHY DON'T
WE GO AHEAD AND ASK. STILL BE
ON. ABSOLUTELY AND- SO WITH
RESPECT TO TESTING WE DO
BELIEVE THAT OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
THE RESOURCES FOR TESTING- FOR
THE OUTDOOR SPORTS- ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE THAT'S ALSO BEING
ASSISTED TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- THROUGH THEIR
VALENCIA LABS AND BECAUSE THE
OUTDOOR SPORTS THE TESTING IS
ONE DAY PER WEEK I DO THINK OUR
SCHOOLS ARE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
THATWE HAVE A MUCH GREATER
CONCERN AND WE CONTINUE TO LOOK
FOR GUIDANCE FOR INDOOR SPORTS
THAT ARE UNDER THE INSTITUTE
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION GUIDANCE
WERE TESTING HAS TO BE ON A
MORE FREQUENT BASIS- THAT'S
WHERE OUR CONCERN LIES. WE
WOULD WE WOULD ADVOCATE THAT
BECAUSE OF THE AGE OF THE
STUDENT ATHLETES AND THE
TESTING IN THE EASE OF TESTING
FOR OUR SCHOOLS THAT FOR
OUTDOOR IN ORDER SPORTS IT WAS
THE SAME CADENCE OF TESTING OF
ONE DAY A WEEK- SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE AN EQUITABLE RETURN. AND
AS DOCTOR CAN- SIX. ON STILL
LIKE TO MAYBE NO VISIT IS
OPINION TO THE QUEST. FOR
SECONDARY YES. I'M ON. SO- YEAH.
THE WANT ME TO REPEAT THAT ARE
YOU ARE YOU ARE OTHERS OPEN
FOR- SPORTS GARLING HAVE BEEN
IN AN EGG AND THE QUESTION FOR
YOU ALSO AROUND TEN DO HAVE THE
AND RESOURCES. YEAH SO ALSO.
FIRST- I BELIEVE. THERE IS A-
VARIETY. OF AVAILABLE
RESOURCES. ON SCHOOL SO I CAN'T
I CAN SAY FOR US. WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE TESTING THERE'S A
LOT OF- RESOURCES OUT THERE
THAT HAVE BEEN WILLING TO HELP
US. SPARSE OTHER STATES.
PROBABLY THE BEST WAY TO PUT IT
IS- CALIFORNIA IS BY FAR THE
MOST RESTRICTIVE- WHETHER
PEOPLE THINK THAT'S GOOD OR
BAD. IT'S THE MOST RESTRICTIVE
WHEN IT COMES TO- OPENING UP
FOR SPORTS- AND- REALLY IT
COMES DOWN TO CONTACT TRACING.
TESTING AND THEN BACKS NATIONS
AS FAR AS THE AREAS THAT. HAVE
BEEN BENEFICIAL FOR OPENING UP-
OTHER STATES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI. OKAY ONE
OF THE PANEL MEMBERS ARE CAN-
AND THIS QUESTION- ALSO
MENTORING IF YOU'RE CAN-
EXPLAINED TO ME- ARE THE IMPACT
OF THE STATE'S SUPPLIED LINES.
I'VE HAD A ON THOSE CHILDREN
AFTER LEASE. WHERE THERE
COUNTERPARTS IN ORDER CITIES.
HAVE A UP- QUICKER THAN A WAR
OWN. ARE WE GO BACK TO DOCTOR
KENNETH A SIXTEEN SINCE HE'S ON
THERE- THAT'S PROBABLY MORE OF
AN OPINION IN A QUICK ANSWER
BUT GO AHEAD AND LET US KNOW
WHAT YOU THINK OF OUR ATHLETES
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES. STILL
MY VIEW ON THAT IS. OUR STATE
GUIDANCE HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
HELPFUL. BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S AN ASSUMPTION EVEN
NATIONALLY THAT THE NCAA IS
SETTING THE ROLE ALL THE
COLLEGES. AND THAT'S JUST NOT
THE CASE IT'S WE TAKE OUR STATE
GUIDANCE AND WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH- SO I BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA'S. AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL POSSIBLE WHEN IT COMES TO
PROVIDING APPROPRIATE GUIDANCE.
IN OTHER WORDS. OUR STAYED WITH
SO MUCH STRICTER AND- OR SOUL-
STAY. LOS OLE. SO ON. WAS THERE
ANY NAY IN UPON OUR ATHLETES.
YEAH THE I HAVE BEEN LIMITED SO
WHEN IT COMES TO EXPERIENCE
CHILLED LEARNING WHEN IT COMES
TO MENTAL HEALTH AND OVERALL
WELL BEING I BELIEVE WE MAY BE-
BEEN HELD BACK A LITTLE BIT OF
THOSE AREAS. BUT I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT- OPENING UP TOO
SOON A FEW MONTHS AGO COULD
HAVE BEEN DETRIMENTAL TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE. YOU KNOW THAT'S A
WHOLE THERE THAT'S A WHOLE TINY
QUESTION AND ANSWER- HELLO
FORTY EIGHT OTHER STATES. ARE
PLAYED YOU SPORTS BEFORE
CALIFORNIA SO MAYBE A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO BUT THERE ARE MANY
QUESTIONS THAT EVEN GO BACK SIX
MONTHS ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND THANK YOU. CAN I HAVE
A- QUESTION IS. WE'RE GONNA GO
HEAD MOVE TO OUR NEXT PANEL
BECAUSE WERE A FIFTEEN MINUTES
LATE BUT WE WILL YOU WILL BE
BACK TO. THE OTHERS TO SPEAK.
SO WE WANT TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVED OUR NEXT PANEL. WHICH IS
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS OUTLOOK
LESSONS LEARNED IN PLANS FOR
COVE IN NINETEEN. WE HAVE THREE
SPEAKERS WANT TO REMIND YOU YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES EACH. AND
AGAIN THIS IS NOW GOING ON TO
OUR PROFESSIONAL. FIGHTERS MARC
MARTIAL ARTS HEAVY WEIGHT AND
WE HAVE SOME OF THE TOP
SPEAKERS HERE FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO FIRST WE'RE
GONNA INVITE MMHM. MIKE
NEWQUIST WHO IS THE SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE ULTIMATE
FIGHTING CHAMPIONSHIP. WELCOME
MIKE. THANK YOU IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE TODAY. SO MY NAME IS
MIKE NEW QUEST WHEN I SERVED AS
THE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
EVENT ABOUT WOMEN FOR THE UFC
THE WORLD'S PREMIER MIXED
MARTIAL ARTS ORGANIZATION.
AMONG MY RESPONSIBILITIES I
OVERSEE ABOUT MARKETING
TICKETING HOSPITALITY AND
TRAVEL OPERATIONS. AND SINCE
LAST YEAR I'VE OVERSEEN YOUR
CITY'S COPA NINETEEN TESTING
PROGRAM. UFC IS TRULY A GLOBAL
BRAND WE HAVE MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FANS WORLDWIDE AND ARPENTS ARE
BROADCAST TO OVER NINE HUNDRED
MILLION HOMES IN MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE COUNTRIES.
IN FORTY DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
THROUGHOUT OUR COMPANY'S
HISTORY WE ALSO HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF BRINGING UFC
EVENTS TO CALIFORNIA TWENTY
NINE TIMES. MORE CITIES SUCH AS
ANAHEIM LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO
AND SAN DIEGO HAVE GRACIOUSLY
HOSTED US. THE LOGISTICS OF OUR
OPERATIONS ARE COMPLEX AND
AMONG THE MOST UNIQUE IN ALL OF
SPORTS. AS UFC PRODUCES EVENTS
NEARLY EVERY WEEK TRAVELS TO
DIFFERENT CITIES AROUND THE
WORLD. AND HAS NO OFF SEASON.
THIS TIME LAST YEAR AS THE
WORLD WAS SHUTTING DOWN AND
IT'S HUNDREDS OF SPORTS EVENTS
WERE CANCELED. UFC COULD HAVE
SUSPENDED OPERATIONS
INDEFINITELY LIKE OTHER SPORTS
DID. NO DOUBT THAT WOULD HAVE
LED TO STAFF LAYOFFS AND PAY
CUTS. HOWEVER OUR PRESIDENT
DANA WHITE TESTERS TO FIND A
WAY TO PRODUCE UFC EVENTS IN A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR ATHLETES
AND STAFF. SO WE CAN KEEP OUR
BUSINESS STRONG AND OUR STAFF
EMPLOYED. DUE TO THE NATURE OF
OUR SPORT HEALTH AND SAFETY HAS
LONG BEEN A PRIORITY FOR YOUR
SEATS. AND WE HAVE SET THE
STANDARDS FOR INDUSTRY. HOWEVER
WE HAVE TO IMPLEMENT FURTHER
ENHANCE SAFETY MEASURES IN
ORDER TO RETURN TO PRODUCING
LIVE EVENTS. THAT'S THE FIRST
STEP. WE DRAFTED A
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OPERATIONS PLAN IN CONSULTATION
WITH TOP MEDICAL EXPERTS
GOVERNMENT AUTHORITIES AND
HEALTH OFFICIALS THAT WAS FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON COBRA NINETEEN
MEDICATION. THIS THIRTY PAGE
DOCUMENT OUTLINED A VARIETY OF
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES INCLUDING
COVER NINETEEN TESTING
TEMPERATURE SCREENING SOCIAL
DISTANCING YOURSELF PP CLEANING
AND SANITATION PLANS MEDICAL
PROCEDURES AND MUCH MORE. ONCE
WE ARE CONFIDENT IN OUR PLAN WE
SOUGHT TO RETURN TO PRODUCING
LIVE EVENTS AFTER A BRIEF
HIATUS AS A RESULT I'M PROUD TO
SAY THAT YOU HAVE C. WAS THE
FIRST PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
ORGANIZATION IN THE UNITED
STATES TO COME BACK IN THE
CUPBOARD NINETEEN ERA. WHEN WE
PRODUCE THREE SUCCESSFUL EVENTS
IN JACKSONVILLE FLORIDA LAST
MAY. THESE EVENTS WERE FULLY
SANCTIONED BY THE FLORIDA STATE
BOXING COMMISSION AND WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH OUR MEDICAL STAFF
AND STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS.
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA AND MAYOR OF
JACKSONVILLE TO ENSURE THE
APPROPRIATE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTOCOLS WERE IN PLACE. THESE
EVENTS WERE CLOSED TO THE
PUBLIC AND PRODUCED WITH ONLY
ESSENTIAL PERSONNEL IN
ATTENDANCE. FOLLOWING
JACKSONVILLE WE RETURN TO OUR
HOME CITY OF LAS VEGAS FOR A
SERIES OF EVENTS AND- UFC
PREPARATION WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE NEVADA STATE
ATHLETIC COMMISSION UNDER
GUIDELINES FROM NEVADA'S
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO FURTHER
REFINE OUR HEALTH AND SAFETY
PLAN. INCLUDING IMPLEMENTING A
BUBBLE LIKE ENVIRONMENT
STRICTER QUARANTINE PROTOCOLS
IN LIMITING THE NUMBER OF
PERSONNEL IN OUR FACILITY. THE
NEXT SERIES OF EVENTS TOOK US
TO ABU DHABI WHAT HAS BEEN
FAMOUSLY GRANTED UFC FIGHT
ISLAND. AS WITH OUR EVENTS IN
JACKSONVILLE IN LAS VEGAS WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE ABU DHABI
AUTHORITIES TO FINE TUNE OUR
HEALTH AND SAFETY PLAN TO
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL COVERT
SAFETY TO COVER TESTING. AND
THE SAFETY ZONE THAT WAS ONLY
OPEN TO U. S. UFC ATHLETES
STAFF. AND ESSENTIAL PERSONNEL.
DESPITE THE LOGISTICAL
CHALLENGES OF TRANSPORTING
NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED UFC STAFF
AND ATHLETES TO ABU DHABI.
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY MINIMIZING
THE RISKS OF COCA NINETEEN
WHITE ISLAND WAS A MAJOR
SUCCESS. MOST IMPORTANTLY THERE
WERE ZERO POSITIVE CODE
NINETEEN CASES AMONG THE UFC
DELEGATION IN ABU DHABI. AND
ALL PERSONNEL RETURN HOME
SAFELY AFTERWARDS. THESE EARLY
EVENTS IN JACKSONVILLE LAS
VEGAS AND ABU DHABI ESTABLISHED
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY ROAD MAP
WE CONTINUE TO USE TO HELP US
PRODUCE EVENTS SAFELY
RESPONSIBLY AND SUCCESSFULLY
WELL WE MANAGED THE CHALLENGES
OF COPING NINETEEN. SINCE THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC. USC HAS
PRODUCED FIFTY EVENTS AND WE
HAVE ADMINISTERED MORE THAN
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND COVER
TASK TO STAFF AND ATHLETES
YIELDING A POSITIVITY RATE OF
ONLY ZERO POINT 86% ZERO POINT
EIGHT SIX PERCENT. WE BELIEVE
THIS TO BE AMONG THE LOWEST
POSITIVITY RATE AMONG
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS. IN SUMMARY
WE CAN HOLD EVENTS SAFELY AND
RESPONSIBLY WHILE MINIMIZING
THE RISKS OF COVERNINETEEN
THIS WAS ONLY POSSIBLE BECAUSE
WE HAVE THE SUPPORT OF TOP
MEDICAL EXPERTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND HEALTH
OFFICIALS AS WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER TO IMPLEMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PLAN. THE CONFORM TO
JURISDICTIONAL GUIDELINES LIKE
THE VENTS ARE THE DNA OF UFC
AND ATTENDING IN PERSON IS THE
MOST IMPACTFUL EXCITING WAY
FANS CAN EXPERIENCE THE SPORT.
OUR RESEARCH INDICATES THERE
NEARLY SIX MILLION UFC FANS IN
CALIFORNIA WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH GOVERNMENT BODIES
SUCH AS THIS DISTINGUISHED
COMMITTEE TO ESTABLISH A PATH
TO BRING UFC EVENTS BACK TO
THIS GREAT STATE. STATE IN A
SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE WAY AND TO
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THESE FANS TO EXPERIENCE WHAT
WE BELIEVE IS THE MOST
THRILLING. SPECTACLE IN ALL
SPORTS I THANK YOU FOR THEIR
TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
AFTER THIS PANEL. THANK YOU
MIKE THE NEW. SENIOR PRESIDENT
OF ALL TO MEANT FIGHTING
CHAMPIONSHIP. WE WANT WHAT YOU
WANT WE WANT TO BRING BACK
SPORTS LIVE SPORTS PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS AS SOON AS SAFELY. AS WE
CAN NEXT WE HAVE ANDY FOSTER
WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ATHLETIC COMMISSION AND WE
WELCOME ANTI. THANK YOU
CHAIRWOMAN MCCORMACK SILVA AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANKS TO DANA MITCHELL FOR THE
INVITATION- I WANTED TO START
BY SHARING MY- WITH THE WITH
BOB- WITH THE POWER THAT I
CREATED- AT A LOT OF THE ALL
THE- IN MY POWER POINT OR- THE-
CAL. BY THAT WE CREATE- USING
THE RIGHT. SO ME JUST THE- TRY.
FIND IT- SO- WE WILL KNOW THE
BACKGROUND OF HOW WE GOT HERE
IN MARCH FOURTH OF LAST YEAR
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY WAS
DECLARED IN SHORTLY THEREAFTER-
THE COMMISSION CANCELED- ALL
ALL SPORTING A BEARD-
PROFESSIONAL SPORTING AMBIENCE-
AND DURING THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY WE GOT THE GREEN
LIGHT TO GO AHEAD AND- THE
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS WILL BE
COMING BACK. THE COMMISSION
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
REGULATION UNIT IN CREATED- A
REGULATORY SCHEME. AND USED A
MARKET SEE REGULATION PROTOCOLS
AND WENT THROUGH THE OFFICE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. AND CREATE
A CITY OF TOP SEED WE HAVE
REGULAR CAST WE HAVE- THE MAN
THE GLOVE BURST EFFECTIVE WITH
MY- THE DECISION. EVERY THAT
YOU KNOW THE BULB IS NOT- WE
YOU IN LOOKED AT A LOT OF THE-
SIX IS THE U. S. HAD JACKSON.
AND ALSO LOOK AT SOME OKAY WILL
MAKE WE CAN DO THIS WE CAN DO
THIS WE LEARN FROM THAT
EXPERIENCE AND SO WHAT WE
DEVELOP A PRETTY GOOD A SERIES
OF REGULATE- WE'VE HAD A- VERY
VERY LOW POLICY. RIGHT WE WE'VE
BEEN- NOT AS AS U. S. OF COURSE
WE'VE HAD ABOUT WE CAN TWENTY
FIVE OF THE- VETERAN THOUSAND
TEN. WE NOT HAD THAT MANY PAUL
A THIRD POSITIVE. WHAT HAPPENS-
MEMBERS. A LOT OF TIME BEFORE
BERMAN WITH. A PUT A NATIONALLY
OR CAMP ON THE CARD GO AWAY AND-
CHECK THEM BEFORE THEY BEFORE
WE SEE THEM WHEN TESTS THAT CAN.
MAY SURE THE THERE. THAT
THEY'RE GOOD SO- THAT'S WHAT
THAT ABOUT- MOVING FULL. MOVE
FORWARD WE CAN GOING TO CAN YOU
THE SAY. RECKONED TO USE THE
BUBBLE. WE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
TESTING WE LEARNED A LOT OF
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF TESTING AND
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE TO USE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF TEST AND-
BUT IT'S BEEN A REAL LEARNING
EXPERIENCE NOT THINK WE BE
INVOLVED- KNOWLEDGE AS WE WENT
ALONG. AND PERHAPS WE'VE BEEN
OVERLY CAUTIOUS AT TIMES BUT I
WOULD RATHER BE OVERLY CAUTIOUS
TO NOT CAUTIOUS ENOUGH IN THIS
SITUATION- THIS IS A PICTURE I
THOUGHT I WOULD SHOW YOU JUST
SOME EXPERIENCE SOME OF MY
EXPERIENCES IN THE BUBBLE WHEN
I WENT THERE- THE FOOD IS ALL
PACKAGED SEPARATELY SO THAT THE
ATHLETES AND- AND THE STAFF
HAVE TO GET IT SEPARATELY THE
TABLES ARE ALL PUT TOGETHER YOU
HAVE TO CALL TO GET ON THE
ELEVATOR TO RIDE ANYWHERE YOU
HAVE BRACELET OWN. THAT TRACK
YOUR MOVEMENT- YOU GET SCANNED
IN AND OUT EVERYWHERE YOU GO
BACK TO FILL OUT THE SEATS THAT
QUESTIONNAIRE EVERY DAY GET
YOUR TEMPERATURE CHECKED AT
VARIOUS LOCATIONS- AND- YOU
HAVE TO HAVE. ALL THE
DOCUMENTATION IN PLACE- IN
ORDER TO MOVE INSIDE THE
BUBBLE- SO. WITH THAT SAID YOU
KNOW WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
COMING BACK- BEFORE CODE WERE
THE BUSIEST COMMISSION OF THE
COUNTRY. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
IT COMING BACK AND- THAT WILL
RETURN. WE'VE BEEN CONCERNED IN
SOMEONE'S ABOUT THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES BEEN BROUGHT UP
SEVERAL TIMES AND- ONE OF THE
COMMISSIONERS AND- HAD HAD AN
ISSUE WITH IT AND SO WHAT WE
DID- SHE SHE BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION AND WE WORKED CLOSELY
WITH CONSUMER AFFAIRS PUBLIC.
AFFAIRS UNIT. AND WE- ASK SOME
OF OUR CHAMPIONS AND LYFT
VOLUNTEER THEIR TIME AND WE
MADE A NAS MIDDLE HELP VIDEO-
AND WE'VE PUT IT OUT. ON SOCIAL
MEDIA- SO WITH THAT SAID MADAM
CHAIR I'M HAPPY. TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE END OF THE
PANEL. THANK YOU I- REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT PUBLIC
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT YOU MADE I
THINK THAT ATHLETE TO ATHLETE
THAT TYPE OF- MESSAGE COULD BE
VERY INSTRUMENTAL FOR
ESPECIALLY OUR YOUNGER ATHLETES
WHO ARE REALLY- NAVIGATING THIS
FOR MANY OF THEM ON THEIR OWN-
AND A ON THE LAST PANELISTS ON
THIS PARTICULAR PANEL IS MIKE.
MCATEE WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF U. S. BOXING MIKE.
AFTERNOON- SHARE- IS WORK
SHAUNA- IN DURING PANEL
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS MIKE NINETY
I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
USA BOXING A USA BOXING IS ONE
OF FIFTY NATIONAL GOVERNING
BODIES CERTIFIED BY- THE UNITED
STATES OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC
COMMITTEE I'M HERE IN COLORADO
SPRINGS COLORADO ONE BIG CITY
USA FONG AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS- ARE PRETTY
COMMON NUMBERS OF FIFTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS- THIS YEAR
WE'RE DOWN. TO SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO REPRESENT OUR
SCHOOL WORK AND OTHER USE OR
NATIONAL GOVERNING BODY SPORTS.
THAT IMPACT- ALL ARE- DIFFERENT
NATIONAL GOVERNING BODIES FROM
USA BOXING TO DIFFERENT COMBAT
SPORTS WITHIN THE ANTI BEES AND
THEN ALSO- REGULAR SPORTS-
FAQIH HI CUANDO ATTRACTED BILL.
AND IF IT WOULD BE OKAY THE
HOMICIDE LIKE TO SHARE. MY
SCREEN I HAVE A SMALL- OUR
POINT THAT I CAN ADD TO IT. YES.
I CAN BE THERE WE GO. WE COULD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEE THAT-
NOT IS FC IS A CAMINO YES THERE
IT IS THERE IT IS YES. THANK
YOU- I JUST WANTED HOW WE GOT
TO WHERE WE'RE AT IN USA BOXING
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
SHARE A FEW THINGS CURRENTLY-
WE LIKE EVERYONE ELSE IN MARCH
WE SHUT DOWN- AND- THEN AS WE
NOTICED IN DIFFERENT STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY
APPROXIMATELY ON MARCH TWENTY
SECOND- WE WERE SHUT DOWN BY
MAY TWENTY SECOND. WE HAD OF
SOME FORM OF BOXING- ACROSS THE
COUNTRY KNOWING THAT BOXING
WOULD OCCUR- UP MARGINS WE CAME
OUT WITH OUR BACK TO BOXING
PROTOCOLS IN JUST A NATIONALLY
STARTED WITH OUR- GUIDELINES
FOR DIFFERENT BOXING GYMS WHAT
DID HAPPEN WAS- AS WE WERE ABLE
TO GO BACK TO BOXING ON JULY
ELEVENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY. WE
HAD OUR FIRST BOXING
COMPETITIONS ONE BEING IN
NEBRASKA ONE BEING IN FLORIDA
AND SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE HAD
OVER A HUNDRED. USA BOXING
SANCTIONED EVENTS ACROSS THIRTY
TWO DIFFERENT STATES CURRENTLY
WE HAVE FORTY THREE EVENTS-
SCHEDULED ACROSS THE STATES
THAT ARE OPEN FOR US TO DO SUCH
AND THEN- WERE VERY. EXCITED IN
THAT- NEXT WEEK WE WILL HAVE
OUR TWENTY TWENTY NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIPS WITH WERE
CANCELED- IN DECEMBER IN
LOUISIANA WILL HAVE OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED BOXERS
COMPETING IN FOUR DIFFERENT
RINGS- IT WILL BE THE LARGEST
BOXING BY USA BOXING EVENT IN
OUR HISTORY- BUT AS OUR EXACT
ARE. WATCHING DIRECTOR LIKES TO
SAY IT WILL BE THE LARGEST
BOXING EVENT WITH THE SMALLEST
OF NOT NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THE
NINETY THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
HERE- ARENA SO NO FANS
LEVITATING BY EVERYTHING WE CAN
DO. USA BOXING HAS FIFTY SIX
NATIONAL OR LOCAL BY ACTUALLY
COMMITTEES FOR THEM IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE A
COMBINED OPERATION BUDGET OF A
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT AS WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING PANELISTS DISCUSSED OF
LIKE UFC BY ANY FOSTER WITH
THE- ATHLETICA. DOES AFFECT JOB
WORKING WITH US BACKED UP
BECAUSE WE ARE A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION- WE DON'T HAVE THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE LIKE A SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO DO TESTING AND OR
LIKE. A COLLEGIATE SPORT- ONE
OF THE IMPORTANT THINGS AND I
THINK- THAT HAS BEEN BROUGHT TO
ATTENTION IS YOU KNOW
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES USA
BOXING- AND I'M USING TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN NUMBERS JUST
BECAUSE IT'S- MORE ACCURATE OF
WHAT WE'RE WE CAN SAYS STOP.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE NINETY OR 84%
OF OUR BOXERS ARE MINORITIES-
AND THEN WE ALSO- AND THAT'S-
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN. 72%
OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN ONE OF
THE PILLARS AS WELL IF YOU LOOK
AT OUR NUMBERS THAT WE DO HAVE.
LAST FEMALE BOXERS BUT THEY
HAVE THE EXACT SAME-
OPPORTUNITIES WE DO NOT TREAT-
BOXERS DIFFERENT IF THEY'RE
MALE OR FEMALE- EVEN AT THE
OLYMPIC LEVEL OF THE FUNDING IS
EXACTLY THE SAME- FOR BOTH
GENDERS. HOW ARE COMPANIES TO
IMPACTED OUR MEMBERSHIP AND
MOST YOUTH SPORTS GROUPS- WERE
DOWN 67% OVER THE EXACT SAME
TIME LAST YEAR SO THAT IS.
IMPACTING OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO OUR BOXERS
OUR COACHES AND ARCHANGELS.
CURRENTLY USA BOXING IS ONE OF
THE WAR. ORG DELEGATIONS HAVE
BEEN RECOGNIZED BY A CEASE ACT-
CALIFORNIA MATURE MIXED MARTIAL
ARTS CAMEL. UNITED STATES FIVE
LEAGUE AND THEN THE
INTERNATIONAL KICKBOXING MORE
TYPE FEDERATION ALL OF US ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT TO ANY
FOSTER AND THE- C. C. SACK.
GROUP AND THEN ALSO THEIR
EXECUTIVE BOARD AND ALSO THE
COMMITTEE SO WE'RE HIGHLY
REGULATED NOT ONLY BY WELL US
NEWS WHEN IT COMES TO THE-
UNITED STATES OLYMPIC
PARALYMPIC COMMITTEE. IN
CALIFORNIA WERE ALSO REGULATED
BY THE ATHLETIC COMMISSION AND
FOR THE SUPPORT OF AMATEUR
BOXING WE'RE ALSO REGULATED BY
FORTY NINE OTHER. STATES WHEN
IT COMES TO BOXING. IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE- SIX HUNDRED
NINETY NINE GEMS LAST YEAR OR
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE PUT
ON A HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
EVENTS. WHAT WE'RE FINDING IN
WITH. ALL OUR BOXING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IS THAT ARE YOU BOXES
ARE SUFFERING WHEN IT COMES TO
NOT BEING ABLE TO BE PART OR BE
ABLE TO BE A WITH THEIR
CULTURES WHICH ALL OF YOU HAVE
TALKED ABOUT BEING. A ATHLETE
YOU KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
MENTORSHIP OF YOUR CULTURE IT'S
THE IMPORTANCE OF SOCIAL GROUPS
AND THAT SENSE OF PURPOSE OF
EVERYBODY. BODY BELONGING AND
THEN EVERYBODY TO A COMMON
GOAL. USA BOXING SPONSORS AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMMING WHICH ARE
VITAL GLOVES NOT GUNS BOOKS
BEFORE BOXING. AND WE ALSO.
SERVE IN OUR COMMUNITY. ONE OF
THE THAT WE WOULD BURKE THE
LOOK AT IS WE HAVE BEEN I DON'T.
COM SPORTS YES HIGH RISK- BUT
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS- IN
BOXING IN SPECIALLY AND AMATEUR
SPORTS AND ARE PART OF GROUPS
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT THEY ARE
SHORTER THEIR INDIVIDUAL- CAN
CONTESTANTS SO WE'RE NOT HAVING
ELEVEN FOOTBALL PLAYERS GO
AGAINST ELEVEN FOOTBALL PLAYERS
AND ANOTHER. YOU KNOW TWENTY ON
THE SIDELINES BY INDIVIDUAL
SPORTS WHICH HELPS WITH SOCIAL
DISTANCING IT ALSO LIMITS A LOT
OF THE CONCERNED WHEN YOU HAVE
LARGE GROUPS BECAUSE YOU ARE
COMPETING ONE ON ONE. OF FOR
USA BOXING THE MAXIMUM LENGTH
OF ANY BALLOT WILL BE NINE
MINUTES. I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE WELL WE HAVE FOUR
FOUR OLYMPIC QUALIFYING BOXERS
OF R. THIRTEEN THERE FROM
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK RICHARD
TORAHS FROM A CALIFORNIA- SUMS
IT UP OF. WHAT WE THINK BASTON
OF LIKE THREE TO LISTEN WHAT
RICHARD HAS TO SAY.
BUT A
LITTLE TECHNICAL ISSUE. THE
VIDEO SOUND ON THE POWER POINT
IS NOT COMING THROUGH. OKAY I
DON'T KNOW I AM IT IS. YEAH
I'LL STOP SHARING. I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT- RESIDENTIALLY WHICH
RICHARD SAID IS THAT BOXING IS
HELP CHANGE AND SAVE HIS LIFE
LIKE MOST OF OUR BOXERS OUT
THERE SO- AND HE'S LOOKING
FORWARD TO BE ABLE I HAVE KIDS
BACK IN THE GYM- SO THEY CAN
TRADE I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT OUR
OLYMPIC QUALIFYING TEAM WILL BE
IN CHULA VISTA FOR FORTY THREE
DAYS ARE STARTING AT THE END OF
THE MONTH- TRAINING AND GETTING
READY FOR OUR OLYMPIC
QUALIFYING EVENT IN ARGENTINA-
WHICH WILL BE A MAY AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY THE- OLYMPIC GAMES IN
TOKYO SO CALIFORNIA IS A HUGE
RESOURCE FOR US AND WE'RE
LOOKING. FORWARD TO BE A BACK
TO BOXING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK- THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
US. ALL OF YOU SCORCHED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU
AGAIN WE- I AM CONTINUING TO
HEAR THE SAME THEMES WHICH ARE
AT. THE IMPACT ON OF COURSE ARE
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES BUT
CERTAINLY ARE YOUNG ADULTS AND
WE KNOW THAT EVEN PREPARING FOR
THE OLYMPICS IF THEY CAN'T GET
INTO THOSE BOXING RINGS THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE AS COMPETITIVE
AND WE WANT TO SEE THOSE
CHAMPIONSHIP. RIGHT. ALL RIGHT
THAT ENDS OUR- THIRD PANEL AND
WITH THAT I WILL BRING IT TO
NOW- BECAUSE I CAN'T SEE OUR
WEB ACCESS- THE MEMBERS HAD A
WILL I KNOW IF THEY WANT TO ASK
A QUESTION. ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THEM NO OUR ANY QUESTIONS ALL
RIGHT SO THAT'S GONNA MOVE US
TO OUR LAST PANEL RECREATION
YOUTH IN NY SPORTS COVERED
NINETEEN PLANS ROUTE FOR
RETURNING TO COMPETITION. AND
THIS PANEL WILL END OF MANY
MANY INCREDIBLE SPEAKERS BUT I
DO WANT TO SAY THAT WE WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HEARD FROM
EVERYONE AND WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE- THAT AS CALIFORNIANS WE
HEAR WHAT'S WORKING WE HEAR THE
AREAS THAT WE NEED TO IMPROVE
AND ALSO- ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND BEGAN WITH MATT
DUARTE WHO IS THE- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RECREATION AND
PARK. DISTRICT. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND- YOU HEAR ME I HANG ON
THERE YOUR- ALL RIGHT YOU'RE
HERE GREAT. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS MATTHEW
TOWARDS A AND IN ADDITION TO
BEING A FATHER TO THREE ACTIVE
CHILDREN AGES TEN EIGHT AND
FOUR I'M AN ATTORNEY A FORMER
ELECTED OFFICIAL OF MY LOCAL
PARKS BOARD AND CURRENTLY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICT
SUPPORT. C. A. R. P. IT IS
COMPRISED OF OVER SIXTY PUBLIC
RECREATION PARK DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR MEMBER AGENCIES
HAVE A SERVICE TERRITORY OF
OVER SIX MILLION ACRES IN WHICH
THEY MAINTAIN AND OPERATE A
MULTITUDE OF LOCAL PARKS. OPEN
SPACES AND COMMUNITY RECREATION
FACILITIES THAT ARE VISITED
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION TIMES
EVERY YEAR. AND ARE PRESENTING
A LARGE SEGMENT OF THE PUBLIC
PARK AND RECREATION FACILITY
OPERATORS IN THE STATE. WE
REGULARLY PARTNER WITH
THOUSANDS OF U. SPORTS
ORGANIZATIONS TO OPERABLE I'D
RANGE OF RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES DID YOU
CALIFORNIA. NOW I THOUGHT A LOT
ABOUT WHAT TO SAY IT CITIES
HEARING AND I COULD SHARE
STATISTICS LIKE THAT FROM A
RECENT STUDY WHICH FOUND THAT
83% OF ADULTS. LEAGUE PARKS AND
OPEN SPACES TO BE ESSENTIAL TO
THE PENCE VISIBLE WELLBEING. I
COULD GO ON ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF PARKS AND RECREATION
AND MENTION THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS GENERATED
PART LOCAL ECONOMIES. I
CALIFORNIA YOUTH SPORTS
TOURNAMENTS ALONE. I CAN TELL
YOU ABOUT THE WELL DOCUMENTED
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS OF ACCESSIBLE AND
EQUITABLE RECREATION FOR YOUTH
AND ADULTS ALIKE. I COULD TELL
YOU ALL THOSE THINGS. WHICH YOU
ALREADY KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
RECREATION IS TO OUR STATE AND
IF YOU DIDN'T BEFORE YOU
CERTAINLY DO NOW. WHAT ELSE WE
KNOW IS THAT THE FIRST STAGE OF
HEALING IN OUR COMMUNITIES THE
FIRST STAGE OF A TRUE RECOVERY
NOT JUST ECONOMIC BUT OF MIND.
SPIRIT AND BODY THE FIRST AID
TO BRING OTHERS TOGETHER AGAIN
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AT OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD BALL FIELDS. OUR
COMMUNITY CENTERS AT OUR LOCAL
PARKS THE JOY THAT THESE
ACTIVISTS BRING TO US ALL IT'S
GOING TO COME AGAIN IT'S GOING
TO COME SOON. NOT BEHALF OF THE
PARKS AND REC PROFESSIONALS AND
ELECTED OFFICIALS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. I CAN SAY THAT WE
ARE READY TO SEARCH. FOR
DRESSING WHAT'S AHEAD FOR OUR
SECTOR DID WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT SPEAK TO WHAT THE PAST
YEAR IS DONE THE PUBLIC
RECREATION PARK AGENCIES.
RECREATION DOES NOT BEEN ALL
FUN AND GAMES BUT THROUGH IT
ALL WE HAVE SHOWN UP. REMAINING
OPEN AND AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC WHICH HAS BEEN A
PRIORITY OF THE STATE. THIS OF
COURSE IS EXPOSED AFTER THE
VIRUS AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN
OUTBREAKS AND QUARANTINE SAID
OF STRETCH PERSONNEL EVEN
FURTHER. SO OUR USAGE HAS
INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY SOME
ESTIMATES THAT 40% GREATER
FREQUENCY. OUR REVENUES HAVE
DROPPED PRECIPITOUSLY. RANCHO
SIMI RECREATION AND PARK
DISTRICT IN SIMI VALLEY ALREADY
RECOVERING FROM THE DEVASTATING
WARS HE FIRED NOVEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A SENIOR REVOLUTION
REVENUE LOSS EXCEEDING FOUR
MILLION AND WAS PART OR STEPPER
LOW OVER TWO HUNDRED EMPLOYEES.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE VALLEY WIDE
RECREATION PARK DISTRICT
OPERATES THE. TIME VALUE OF
QUANTIC CENTER ABOUT I DON'T
COMMUNITY RESOURCE AND HEMET.
AND THEY HAVE. THREE HUNDRED.
THOUSAND AND WITH POLL. AND
THEY STILL HAVE TO EXPAND- OVER
TO HER FIFTY. PER FOR WATER FOR
CHEMICALS EVERYTHING THAT GOES
INTO MAINTAINING AQUATIC
FACILITY. THE CROSS THE STATE
WE'RE LOOKING AT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS IN LOST REVENUE.
COUPLED WITH ADDITIONAL
MILLIONS IN A BUDGET CODE
RELATED EXPENDITURES AND JOB
LOSSES IN THE THOUSANDS. AT THE
SAME TIME PUBLIC RECREATION
FACILITIES CONTINUE TO BE
CALLED UPON TO SERVE AS A VITAL
PART OF EMERGENCY AND DISASTER
RESPONSE. IN ORANGE COUNTY
SILVERADO MODJESKA RECREATION
PARK DISTRICT HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE COMMUNITIES
DISASTER RELIEF EFFORTS AFTER
WILDFIRES BLAZE THROUGH THE
CANYONS. MISSIONARY AGENCIES
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN CALLED
UPON TO SERVE AS TESTING SITES
AND NOW BACKSEAT CLINICS.
CLINICS MAKING SURE THESE VITAL
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE TO THE ELDERLY AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
PARKS AND REC SERVICES HAVE
ALSO BEEN MODIFIED TO COMPASS
DAYCARE IN DISTANCE LEARNING
SERVING AS RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE AND
EDUCATIONAL SUPPORT DURING OUR
STATE'S MOST PRESSING
TYPEWRITTEN. BURKE PARKS AND
REC PROFESSIONALS WE'VE
CONTINUOUSLY ADAPTED TO
WHATEVER CONSTITUENTS MAY NEED
A DESPITE RISING TO THE
CHALLENGE OF TWENTY TWENTY. OUR
AGENCIES HAVE NOT RECEIVED A
FINANCIAL SUPPORT NECESSARY TO
ENSURE. INDEPENDENT
INDISPENSABLE SERVICES CONTINUE
TO BE AVAILABLE AND OUR
EXPANDED TO ENSURE A FAIR AND
JUST ACCESS. BOTH FEDERAL
RELIEF PACKAGES. FAILED TO
DIRECTLY ALLOCATE ANY FUNDING
TO SPECIAL DISTRICTS WHICH
MEANT THAT THOSE AGENCIES
PROVIDING CORE PUBLIC SERVICES
LIKE RECREATION PARK DISTRICTS.
HAVE SUFFERED THE MOST
DIFFICULT FINANCIAL HITS AND
RECEIVEDABSOLUTE ABSOLUTELY
ZERO DOLLARS IN A WEEK. AS TO
WHAT IS TO COME WE APPRECIATE
THE GUIDANCE OF THE CDPH WITH
RESPECT YOUTH AND ADULT SPORTS.
WE CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WELCOMING OUR PUBLIC BACK TO
COMPETITION BUT IMPLEMENTATION
OF THESE HEALTH AND SAFETY
MEASURES WILL COME AT A COST
WITHOUT FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
THIS SPECIAL DISTRICTS LIKE
RECREATIONAL PARK DISTRICT.
THERE WILL CERTAINLY BE AN
IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON THE ABILITY
TO MAKE CERTAIN SPECIAL EVENTS
AND OTHER RECREATIONAL
OFFERINGS AVAILABLE.
FURTHERMORE WE ALREADY LOST A
YEAR OF USEFUL LIFE FOR PUBLIC
FACILITIES AND I THINK IT
LIKELY THAT WE WILL SEE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. SLOWED
IMPLEMENTATION OF CAPITAL
PROJECTS AND DELAYS AND OTHER
NEW DEVELOPMENTS. THOROUGHLY
JUST WANT TO END BY SAYING. WE
DIDN'T STOP AND WE HAVE BEEN
HIT PART OR AGENCIES ARE NOW
CURRENTLY PREPARING TO STEP UP.
IN ANTICIPATION OF A BUSY
SUMMER SEASON. AND BELIEVE ME
WHEN THAT NW GUIDANCE COMES
OUT OUR PHONES ARE RINGING SO
WE KNOW WHAT IS COMING IN AND
WE WILL BE READY. BECAUSE
FRANKLY OUR ECONOMY NEEDS IT
OUR COMMUNITY IS NEEDED IN OUR
CHILDREN. BUT SPECIAL DISTRICTS
LIKE OURS TO BE GOING IT ALONE
WE HOPE THAT WE CAN COUNT ON
RELIEF TO COME SOON. SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
I THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION. THANK YOU
MATT EXCEPTIONAL TESTIMONY I
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS
A- FORMER CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
AND NATIONALLY A PARKS AND
RECREATION COMMISSIONER. AND
EVERYTHING THAT YOU SAID IS
SPOT ON AS- THINGS HAVE CLOSED
DOWN LESS REVENUE AND AGAIN-
THOSE ARE THE PLACES THAT
PEOPLE GO TO FIRST. TO THE
PARKS FOR PICNICS TO WALKING
THE TRAILS. UP WHEN POSSIBLE
THOSE YOUTH SPORTS AND OF
COURSE. I KNOW THERE'S PEOPLE-
REALLY HOPING FOR SOME
FIREWORKS THIS. FOURTH OF JULY
AND THOSE ARE USUALLY UP PUBLIC
PLACES SO WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
OUR FINGERS CROSSED I NEXT WE
HAVE CO FOUNDER OF LET THEM
PLAY BRAD HENSLEY. WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH EVERYONE SO. MY
QUALIFICATIONS ARE- VERY
UNIMPRESSIVE IN- WHY WHY I'M
HERE TODAY I'M A I'M A FATHER
OF. THREE I HAVE A FOOTBALL
PLAYER AND I HAVE TWO DAUGHTERS
THAT ARE COMPETITIVE DANCERS.
AND LIKE A LOT OF PARENTS AND
MY WIFE AND I WERE VERY PATIENT
THROUGH- THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
I'M STARTING BACK IN MARCH-
YEAH WE'RE PATIENTS OF THE
SUMMER WHEN THE STATE PUSHED
GUIDANCE THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
COMING WHERE PATIENTS IN THE
FALL. WHEN THE STATE PUSHED
GUIDANCE THAT WE SAW ALL THESE
OTHER STATES PLANE YOU SPORTS-
AND THEN WE GOT THE GUIDELINES
IN THE MIDDLE OF DECEMBER IN
TERMS OF THE TEARS AND WHAT
WOULD BE ALLOWED IN AND WE
QUICKLY REALIZED THAT. THERE
WAS NOT. SHORT OR EASY PATH.
FOR OUR KIDS TO GET THE MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF AND IN TERMS OF
IN TERMS OF ANYTHING. UNLESS
THE KIDS GOOD FOR PRIVATE
SCHOOL THEY WENT ON THE SCHOOL.
PARKS WERE CLOSED CHURCHES WERE
CLOSED AND THERE WERE NO SPORTS.
SO- IT WAS MY WIFE AND I AND-
WE DECIDED TO DO SOMETHING AND
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE IT WOULD
CALVET WE STARTED A FACEBOOK
PAGE ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
ALONG WITH OUR THIRD CO
FOUNDER- FRIEND AND ATTORNEY.
YEAH I CAN HELP YOU. WE STARTED
WITH THREE PEOPLE ON NEW YEAR'S
EVE THE NEXT DAY WAS FIFTY- THE
NEXT DAY WAS FIVE HUNDRED. AND
WE STARTED TO GROW BY THOUSANDS
EVERY DAY- AND THEN WE
REALIZED. THERE ARE A LOT OF
LIKE MINDED PARENTS OUT THERE
AND ATHLETES AND COACHES THAT.
WANT TO GIVE THESE KIDS A
VOICE- YOU KNOW IN OUR OPINION.
KIDS WERE THE ONLY ONE THAT
DIDN'T GET TO RESTART.
CRITICALLY EVERY INDUSTRY GOT A
CHANCE TO RE OPEN BUT- THE KIDS
THAT- BY THE END OF JANUARY WE
HAD GROWN TO OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS. AND WHAT
STARTED AS A L. AS A SMALL
FACEBOOK PAGE BY TWO PEOPLE BUT
NEVER EVEN DID FACEBOOK BUT-
WE'LL WELL THE SUDDEN. I HAD A
MOVEMENT- OUR MISSION WAS VERY
SIMPLE FROM THE BEGINNING AND
IT REMAINS- AND IT REMAINS
SIMPLE IT WAS- TO BRING BACK.
USE SPORTS TO CALIFORNIA-
SAFELY AND IMMEDIATELY. AND I
THINK WHAT WAS DIFFERENT ABOUT
OUR ORGANIZATION AND I THINK
WHAT WE'RE REALLY WORKED WELL
AS WE WANTED TO DO IT THE RIGHT
WAY- WE- WE DID NOT VIEW THIS
AS POLITICAL WE CERTAINLY
DIDN'T VIEW THIS AS- PARTISAN-
WE HAVE STRICT STANDARDS IN
TERMS OF MODERATING WHAT WAS
ALLOWED. AND WE ARE NOT A
RECALL SITE AND WE KEPT ALL
THAT OUT OF THAT BECAUSE
BASICALLY. KIDS THAT ARE
PLAYING SPORTS THEY JUST WANT
TO PLAY SPORTS ARE NOT
DEMOCRATS OR REPUBLICANS- SO WE
CAPTURE THAT MISSION AND IT WAS
DIFFICULT AT TIMES TO KEEP
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE FROM
CURRENT. GOING IN THAT ROUTE
BUT I THINK THAT TRULY TRULY
HELPED US ACCOMPLISH OUR GOAL-
SO HOW WE DID IT WE EMPLOYED A
VARIETY OF STRATEGIES AND
THERE'S THREE REFORMS OFF I'LL
TALK ABOUT IS WHEN WE NEEDED TO
GET THE DATA. TO PROVE IT WAS
SAFE IN WHAT WAS HAPPENING TO
OUR KIDS. TO WE NEED TO
ORGANIZE TO BRING ATTENTION AND
LEVERAGE THE MEDIA TERMS OF OUR
CAUSE. AND THREE WE ALSO HAD TO
GET SUPPORT FROM A VARIETY OF
OTHER- RIGHTY EITHER
ORGANIZATIONS WITHIN CALIFORNIA
SO FROM A DATA STANDPOINT WE
LOOKED INTERNALLY IN
CALIFORNIA. WE LOOK AT THE-
SPORTS THAT WERE PRACTICING
UNDER CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENTS
IS COLDAND WE GOT A MILLION
DATA POINTSTO SHOW THAT THE
KIDS. ARE VERY LOW RISK IN
TERMS OF CONTRACTING AND
SPREADING COLD INTO THE LARGER
COMMUNITY. WE WENT NATIONAL TO
THE FORTY PLUS STATES AT THE
TIME THAT WERE SEIZED. SAFELY
AND SUCCESSFULLY- COMPETING IN
YOUR SPORTS- AND ALSO LOOK AT
INDEPENDENT STUDIES- WE THEN
TURNED OUR ATTENTION ONCE WE
PROVE THAT WE CAN DO IT SAFELY.
FOR YOU SPORTS WE LOOK AT THE
MENTAL HEALTH SIDE. WE LOOK
THAT THE SO WEEK. AND BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WHO WAS PLANS FOR CLUB
SPORTS THE ONLY THE THAT COULD.
IT MORE. THOUSANDS WERE
TRAVELING OUT OF STATE THERE IS
ONLY AND UTAH AND YOU NAME IT
IN UNCONTROLLED ENVIRONMENTS
THAT. JUST DIDN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE TO US. AND THERE'S ALSO A
LOT OF CYBER CRIMES BEING.
COMMITTED AGAINST OUR OUR OUR
OUR KIDS SUMMER STAFF IN THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF SAN DIEGO
IS A MEMBER OF OUR COSTS AND-
AND SHARE THAT INFORMATION
WITH. WITH THE MEDIA ITSELF
VERY ALARMING. SO I'VE WE'VE-
GOT THE DATA WE ORGANIZED AS
GROUPS AND WE DID THAT RIGHT
AWAY IS ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS WE DID IT
THROUGH PEACEFUL PROTESTS AND
RALLIES ACROSS THE STATE-
BELIEVES JANUARY NINETEENTH. WE
CONDUCTED A HUNDRED FIFTY OF
THESE ACROSS THE STATE WITH
OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND NOW
PARTICIPANTS- VERY SUCCESSFULLY
SOCIALLY DISTANCE MAST. GIVING
OUR KIDS A VOICE AND I THINK
FOR THE FIRST TIME. WE SAW HOPE
IN OUR KIDS LIVES THAT. MAYBE
MAYBE AMERICAN PLAY SPORTS. THE
FINAL OUR STRATEGY THAT WE
EMPLOY WAS ARE GETTING SUPPORT
FROM THOSE THOSE AREAS THAT WE
FELT THAT WE WOULD NEED IT.
UNCLEAN THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
WERE MEDICAL DOCTORS AND-
DISEASE SPECIALISTS- QALAT
LETTERS. TO THE GOVERNOR SAYING
HEY WE SUPPORT OF BRINGING BACK
U. SPORTS. OF THE LEGISLATURE I
WOULD SPECIFICALLY LIKE TO CALL
OUT STEVEN CHOI. AS A AS A- AS
AN ADVOCATE OF ARSIA- COAL- CO
SIGNED A- BIPARTISAN LETTER-
WHICH WE HAD THE MAJORITY OF.
THE ASSEMBLY- SUPPORTING A
LETTER WRITTEN GOVERNOR SOME TO
BRING BACK OUTDOOR SPORTS. AND
THE FINAL STRATEGY WORTH
MENTIONING. WAS- WE LEVERAGE
THE LEGAL SYSTEM. HE WILL
PUBLISHED THAT INSTEAD DIEGO.
WE ARE WE FILED. OF AN EQUAL UP.
CLAUSE AGAINST THE COUNTY AND
STATE. I'M NOT FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH WE WON A TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDER THAT ALLOWED.
ALL U. SPORTS IN SAN DIEGO
INCLUDING INDOOR SPORTS.
ASSEMBLY WAS OPREME TEAR FREE-
FOR TWO WEEKS. UNLIKE THE REST
THE STATE UNFORTUNATELY- OUR
ATTORNEYS MYSELF ARE PLAINTIFFS
IN THE STATE CAME TOGETHER. AND
WE CAME WITH THE SETTLEMENT.
THAT BASICALLY EXTENDED THE SAN
DIEGO PROVISIONS TO THE REST OF
THE STATE TO ALLOW ALL U.
SPORTS. TO RETURN BACK TO
CALIFORNIA- YOU KNOW SUBJECT
TO. DIFFERENT GUIDELINES
OUTDOOR VERSES ON VERSUS
INDOOR. THIS WAS A HUGE VICTORY
FOR THE THREE MILLION KIDS
ACROSS THE STATE THAT HAD BEEN
BENCHED- SINCE MARCH- AND. AND
I CAN TELL YOU THE NUMBER OF
MESSAGES AND- POST THANK YOU
FROM TELLING ME THEIR STORIES
OF HOW WHAT A BIG IMPACT THIS
IS HAVING KIDS- THE FIGHT
REMAINS NOW- THERE ARE STILL A
LOT OF BATTLES THAT WE HAVE TO
FIGHT. FOR AS AN ORGANIZATION
AS PARENTS I'M FOR EXAMPLE
SPECTATORS THE STATE GUIDELINES
ARE ONE SPECTATOR- OF THE
IMMEDIATE FAMILY BASIS AND-
THAT JUST DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE TO US WHEN YOU COULD BE
LIKE AN OUTDOOR FOOTBALL
STADIUM SOCIALLY DISTANCE
WEARING MASKS. ONE PERSON KICK
KIDS NEED THE SUPPORT OF THEIR
PARENTS OF THE PARENTS AND
THEIR FAMILY AND THEIR FRIENDS
THERE'S A RIGHT WAY TO DO IT.
ANOTHER THING THAT CAME OUT
TODAY FROM THE- CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH ALSO NEW
GUIDELINES THE CLARIFICATION IS
THEY'VE BAND- SIDELINE CHEER.
ON FRIDAY NIGHTS AND THAT JUST
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO US
HOW CAN IT WE'VE PROVEN THAT
YOUTH FOOTBALL CAN BE DONE
SAFELY THAT'S A VERY HIGH
IMPACT SPORT HOW. HOW SIDELINE
SHEER SOCIALLY DISTANCE
PROBABLY WEARING MASKS THE
MAJORITY OF THE TIME. NOT BE
ACCEPTED SO VERY IDIOSYNCRATIC
IN TERMS OF A LOT OF THE RULES
OUT THERE AND WE'RE DOING OUR
BEST AS AN ORGANIZATION. TO
WORK WITH THE STATE TO TRY TO
RESOLVE SOME OF THIS- ON A
FINAL NOTE LET THEM PLAY WILL
NOT STOP EXISTING WE HAVE. TOO
MANY MEMBERS INTO MANY CAUSES
TO FIGHT FOR- WE'RE NOW FIVE OH
ONE SEE THREE- AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GATHER FUNDS AND WE'VE
ALSO SET UP A FOUNDATION AND-
THOSE ASSETS WOULD THEN BE
DEPLOYED TO NEEDY ATHLETES AND-
AT MEDIA ATHLETIC. PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE. AND AGAIN
THANKS THE PLAN. ON FOR.
ALLOWING US SPLIT FOR. THANK
YOU BRAD AND I FIND YOUR STORY
REALLY INSPIRING THIS IS
EXACTLY HOW YOU GET THINGS DONE
NOT ONLY LOCALLY BUT THROUGH
THE STATE IS BY ADVOCATING AND
YOU CERTAINLY HAVE DONE THAT
I'VE HEARD OF YOU AND SEEING
YOU. JUST ON THROUGH VARIOUS- I
KNOW OUR LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL HAD
A SUCH A SMALL HIGH SCHOOL- LET
THEM PLAY RALLY. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE PART. OF REALLY
TRYING YOUR BEST NOT TO BECOME%
OVERLY POLITICAL BECAUSE YOU
KNOW I ALWAYS SAID WHEN I WAS A
PARKS AND RECREATION
COMMISSIONER AND THIS WAS QUITE
AWHILE AGO BUT ALSO AN
ELEMENTARY TEACHER. YOU GO ONTO
A SOCCER FIELD IT'S NOT
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS WHO
ARE PLAYING IT'S KIDS NEIGHBOR
TO NEIGHBOR COMMUNITY. TO
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S WHEN WE'RE
AT OUR BEST SO I APPRECIATE
THIS WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE
SENSIBLE THE- DECISIONS I DID
HEAR ABOUT THE CHEERLEADERS AND
THAT WE DEFINITELY THAT IS IN
FACT A SPORT. AND I CAN TELL
YOU I HAVE TWO DAUGHTERS TODAY
ST PATRICK'S DAY AND THEY GREW
UP DOING IRISH DANCING. AND
FROM THE TIME THEY WERE
KINDERGARTEN TO HIGH SCHOOL
GOING TO FESTIVALS IN PLANO-
DANCING AT SCHOOLS AND-
AMERICAN LEGION CLUBS AND FAITH
ALL KINDS OF THINGS SO THEY'RE
ALL IT'S A FAMILY AFFAIR WHEN
IT COMES TO SPORTS AND- WE NEED
THE SPECTATORS OF THE FAMILIES
OUT THERE THE GRANDPARENTS
EVERYBODY. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND WE'LL KEEP FIGHTING ALONG
WITH YOU- THANK YOU. WE HAVE
ONE MORE- FOR. HERE ON OUR
PANEL AND I HAVE SPOKEN TO MY
PHONE MORE THAN A FEW TIMES-
AND WHEN HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
INSURANCE BOARDS. AND JUST
AGAIN A GOOD WAY TO SAY THAT
THAT'S ALL THOSE RUNS THAT SOME
OF YOU PREPARE FOR AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO FIVE CASE TEN
CALORIES WALKS CHARITY THAT.
MIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK
SILVA MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO OUR INDUSTRY
AND THE VALUE AND WRAPPED
ROSALIND SAT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO I NAMES LIKE
BONE ON THE FOUNDER AND OWNER
SPECTRUM SPORTS MANAGEMENT A
SMALL BUSINESS LOCATED LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND THIS WAS
JUST OUTLINED WE ORGANIZE AND
MANAGE RUNS WALKS BIKE RIDES
TRIATHLONS AND SIMILAR EVENTS.
MY COMPANY'S BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR TWENTY YEARS UNLIKE PULL
OUT REST OF OUR INDUSTRY WAS
IMMEDIATELY SHUT DOWN JUST OVER
A YEAR. DISTINGUISHING BY MOST
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA BUT
UNLIKE MOST BUSINESSES ARE
INDUSTRY IS YET TO RECEIVE A
PATH OR GUIDELINES MOVING
FORWARD. SO I'D LIKE TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF INTERNET SPORTS
TELL YOU ABOUT OUR IMPACT ON
THE STATE. AND FOR THAT WE DO
HAVE A POWER POINT THAT WILL BE
HAPPY TO SHARE HERE. OF SECOND.
I PROMISE WE HAVE. WE ZERO
RUNNING THERE OKAY THERE YOU GO.
I REQUEST FOR REPORT. HUNDREDS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES OPERATE IN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY SUPPORTING
NONPROFITS ARE LOCAL ECONOMIES
ARE HEALTHY POPULOUS WE
REPRESENT NEARLY EIGHT THOUSAND
EVENTS A YEAR AND TWO MILLION
PARTICIPANTS OF UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. IF YOU'VE EVER
PARTICIPATED IN A LOCAL FIVE K.
OR MARATHON TO RAISE MONEY FOR
A CHARITY WALK OR RUN OR IF YOU
PARTICIPATED IN A BIKE RIDE AND
BIKE RIDE WITH FRIENDS. OR EVEN
COMPLETED AN IRONMAN TRAVEL IN
YOUR PART OF OUR INDUSTRY. OUR
INDUSTRY OUR EVENTS ARE
PARTICIPANTS TO SHOWCASE THE
UNIQUENESS THAT IS. CALIFORNIA
LIFESTYLE. CALIFORNIA IS THE
BIRTHPLACE OF THE SPORT A TRY
APPLE. WE ARE THE ESSENCE OF
HEALTHY OUTDOOR LIVING AND
HEALTHY COMPETITIONS FROM AGE.
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT TWO
HUNDRED WERE PARTICIPATING IN
COMMUNITY EVENTS EVERY WEEKEND
UP AND DOWN THE STATE. 90% OF
OUR INDUSTRY OUR SMALL FAMILY
OWNED BUSINESSES OR NONPROFITS.
THERE'S A STRONG NEED RIGHT NOW
FOR IN CALIFORNIA TO BE SPENT.
OPEN UP OUR INDUSTRY AND WE
WILL WE FILL HOTEL ROOMS
RESTAURANTS AND RENTAL CARS.
YOU NAME IT WE DRIVE ALL AS A
RESULT OF JUST DOING OUR JOB.
INTERN SUPPORTS SPORTS SUPPORT
NONPROFITS IN A NORMAL YEAR.
ARE INDUSTRY IT WILL GENERATE
NEARLY SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN CHARITABLE GIVING AND RABBIT.
IMAGINE THE IMPACT OF THIS
MONEY DISAPPEARING FROM THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR IMPACTING
EVERYONE FROM NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS TO YOUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY NONPROFITS. ACCORDING
TO THE AP ONE OR THREE
NONPROFITS ARE IN FINANCIAL
JEOPARDY FROM THE ECONOMIC
SHUTDOWN ALREADY. WE NEED YOUR
HELP TO RETAIN OPENS WE HAVE
SOME UNIQUE CHALLENGES IN OUR
INDUSTRY. THOSE WAS MENTIONED
AT THE OPENING AN ART WE
OPERATE ON HUGE LEAD TIMES VERY
LARGELY TIMES TYPICALLY NINE TO
TWELVE MONTHS. ABOUT THE TIME
IT TAKES TO BUILD A HOME AND
THAT'S OUR TIME FRAME FOR EVERY
EVENT WE DO. ARBENZ ARE LARGELY
AND- ONCE THE DATE PASSES THE
BAN EXPIRES AND THEY'RE GONE
FOR A YEAR OR FOREVER.
BUSINESSES WILL CLOSE THIS FALL
IF WE CANNOT GET SOME
ASSISTANCE AND RE OPENING NOW.
WE CAN REOPEN SAY FOR WE HAVE
SPENT THE LAST YEAR LOOKING AT
BEST PRACTICES FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY. WE'VE WORKED WITH OUR
NATIONAL GOVERNING BODIES WE
WORK WITH OUR LOCAL COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
RESILIENCY OFFICERS TO ENSURE
THAT WERE READY TO REOPEN. WE
HAVE A SOLID PUBLIC SAFETY PLAN
WHICH HAS BEEN VETTED BY MANY
OF THESE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
THAT WE TALK ABOUT AND IS ALSO
ACCEPTABLE AND AVAILABLE TO THE
COMMITTEE. FURTHER WE HAVE
SCIENCE ON OUR SIDE. WE ARE
OUTDOORS THERE'S TWENTY TIMES
HIGHER LIKELIHOOD OF CONTRACTED
THE COBIT VIRUS INDOORS THAN
OUTDOORS THAT. ACCORDING TO
MULTIPLE STUDIES REPORTS THERE
ARE NO NO NO KNOWN OUTBREAKS OF
THE VIRUS FROM THE OUTDOOR
ENDURANCE IT'S- IF WE ALLOWING
HIGH CONTACT SPORTS AN INDOOR
SPORTS DOES DOES NOT MAKE SENSE
TO US WHY OUR OUTDOOR. DISTANCE
MODIFIED EVENTS ARE NOT
HAPPENING THAT. WE NEED YOUR
HELP IN THREE SPECIFIC POINTS.
CREATE A SUBCLASS OF ENDURANCE
SPORTS IN THE SPORTS THREE
OPENING GUIDELINES PLACES ON
THE OUTDOOR RECREATION SO THERE
WE ARE RECOGNIZED AS AN OUTDOOR
RECREATION ACTIVITY. SIMILAR TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
RECOGNIZING THE SKI INDUSTRY IS
A HEALTHY OUTDOOR ACTIVITY.
THAT'S A GOOD DESCRIPTION OF
WHAT WE DO. AND ALLOW US TO
OPEN IMMEDIATELY WITH
MODIFICATIONS THE SAME AS OTHER
THAN ADULTS SPORTS. WE CAN DO
THIS NOW AS A MATTER OF FACT
FORTY TWO OTHER STATES ARE
EITHER CURRENTLY ALLOW PAIN ARE
CURRENTLY PLANNING AND
PERMITTING. FOR SOME FORM OF
ENDURANCE SPORTS. WE HAVE NO
GUIDELINES FOR OUR BANDS WERE
READY TO GO TO WORK AND WE CAN
DO IT SAFELY. WE HAVE A SHORT
VIDEO THAT DEMONSTRATES OUR
ABILITY TO OPERATE- SPORTS
SAFELY UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT
COOPERATING WITH WEBEX SO WE'RE
GONNA MAKE THAT AVAILABLE TO
THE COMMITTEE TO VIEW IT AS
DIFFERENT TALK. THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US HERE. THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COURTS OF THE
ADVENTUROUS LIKE TO TALK TO AND
GUIDANCE WE KNOW THAT THESE
EVENTS ARE IMPORTANT TO THE
COMMUNITY. THEY KNOW THAT
THERE'S AN ECONOMIC STIMULUS TO
THE COMMUNITIES WE KNOW JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY THAT WITH HEALTHY
ACTIVITIES. LIKE OURS WE
GENERATE HEALTHY LIFESTYLES
MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE AND
PROVIDE OTHER DOCUMENTATION IS
REQUIRED. THANK YOU MIKE AND I
WILL SAY WE KIND OF AND WITH
OUR FORMAL PRESENTATION OR WE
STARTED WHICH WAS ME MAKING A
PLEA TO- ARE- THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH DR ERICA PAIL IN
HAND WHICH IS THAT WE REALLY
THIS. ASSOCIATION ENDURANCE
ASSOCIATION REALLY NEEDS TO
HAVE GUIDELINES AS WAS NOTED
NINE TO TWELVE MONTHS TO PLAN
SO EVEN IF THEY WERE TO GET.
SOME TYPE OF INFORMATION IN THE
BLUEPRINT IN THE NEXT MONTH
THEY'RE STILL NOT ABLE TO GET
ANY EVENT OFF MAYBE WELL INTO
THE FALL AND THIS IS CRIPPLING
TO THEIR INDUSTRY. BUT ALSO AS
WE KNOW TO ALL THE ATHLETES WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS SO THAT
THAT'S JUST A COMMENT BUT I
WILL- ASK OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- WHETHER WEB ACCESS-
HERE IF THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THIS PANEL AND THEN WE WILL
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENTS. SURE I
AM THANK YOU SO MUCH TO ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS DONE ON AND ALL
OF THE PANELS TODAY FOR THIS
ROBUST DISCUSSION- A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MYSELF- AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER I'M AN ATHLETE. AND IN
HIGH SCHOOL I PLAYED BASKETBALL
SOFTBALL VOLLEYBALL. I ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT IMPORTANT
TIMES- IN MY LIFE AND GIVE ME
LOTS OF DIRECTION BUT I'M ALSO
A MOM. A MOM OF A LITTLE GIRL
WHO'S GONNA BE FOUR YEARS OLD
IN A MONTH AND I REMEMBER WHEN
I WAS FOUR YEARS OLD BEING AND
ROLLED INTO BALLS. AND THAT
OPTION IS OPEN FOR HER RIGHT
NOW. AND SO WE HAVE YOU KNOW IT
AND- SO MANY CHILDREN THATNEED
TO BE. IN SPORTS THAT NEED AN
EMOTIONAL OUTLET THAT NEED A
PHYSICAL OUTLET- FOR THE LET
THEM PLAY MOVEMENT FOR BRAD.
WHAT CAN WE BE ADVOCATING FOR
AND DOING HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE- FOR STUDENT
ATHLETES. AND WHAT RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED. AND DO YOU FEEL
LIKE- HAVE YOU HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME OF OUR
PARENTS. OF OUR UNDERSERVED
MINORITY FAMILIES WHO DON'T
HAVE. THE FINANCIAL MEANS AND
RESOURCES TO ENROLL. IN OR PUT
THEIR CHILD CHILDREN- AND
CLUBBER TRAVELING SPORTS. WHAT
I MEAN THOSE ARE SO MANY GOOD
QUESTIONS I HAVE I WAS THIRTY
AND SOME TO MY HEAD AND THEN I
THINK I LOST TRACK OF THEM LET
ME START WITH THE LAST ONE IS
THE UNDERSERVED UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES RIGHT THAT'S A
THAT'S A MAJOR ISSUE AND THAT'S
WHAT LET THEM PLAY IS GOING TO
BE FOCUS MOVING. FORWARD I CAN
TELL YOU THAT WE PARTNERED WITH
CIS EXTENSIVELY- AS WE TRIED TO
BRING BACK ALL USE FOR ITS FOR
EVERYONE A LOT OF THAT HAD TO
DO WITH THE TESTING. RIGHT
BECAUSE WE KNEW TESTING WAS
GONNA GET FIGURED OUT BY THE
HIGH SCHOOLS THAT COULD AFFORD.
AND TESTING WASN'T GONNA GET
FIGURED OUT BY INNER CITY AND
SOMETIMES REMOTE OR OR LOWER
ECONOMIC- THEY SCHOOLS- SO THE
STATE UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT
SUPPORTING- THE TESTING
REQUIREMENTS OF INDOOR SPORTS
THEY'RE ONLY DOING IT FOR
OUTDOOR SPORTS WHAT WE WERE
ABLE TO DO IS COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
OF NO CHARGE FOR ANY ATHLETES
OR ANY SCHOOLS THAT ACTUALLY
WAS MOBILE AND WOULD GO TO THEM
SO THAT THAT WAS ONE OF OUR
BIGGEST WAYS THAT WE WANTED TO
BRING BACK ALL THE U. SPORTS
AND GIVE EVERYONE THE
OPPORTUNITY WITH TESTING REALLY
BEING THE BIGGEST BARRIER
THERE. IN TERMS OF ADVOCACY
WHAT WHAT THE ATHLETES NEED
RIGHT NOW IS THERE IS THERE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT AREAS ONE IS
TESTING REQUIREMENTS- FRANKLY
THE STATE IS BASED ON A LOT OF
THE PROTOCOLS AROUND TESTING
NOT JUST OUTDOOR VERSES INDOOR.
BUT FOR FALSE POSITIVES- AS
WELL AS WHAT HAPPENS- WHAT WHEN
SOMEBODY IS POSITIVE AND THE
OTHER KIDS THAT THAT HAVE TO
QUARANTINE OURS ARE THOSE RULES
THE MOST- RULES MOST UP TO
DATE- I THINK. I MAY ALREADY
MENTIONED- CHEER. I A A A BIG
CONNECTED ISSUE- AND I THINK
THAT. YOU TO BE TO GO TO THAT
THEN ALSO THE SPECTATORS SO IF
YOU LOOK AT OUR PAGING YOU LOOK
WHERE THE- CONCENTRATION IS AND
IT'S PRETTY SPIRITED I PROBABLY
MORE SCARED THAN I'D LIKE.
THOSE ARE THE AREAS THAT- WE
NEED. WE NEED ADVOCACY ON AND
WHERE WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT.
MOVING MOUNTAINS HERE I THINK
THE MOUNDS ALREADY BEEN LET'S
LET'S LET'S LOOK AT SOME. OF
THESE IDIOSYNCRATIC POLICIES
AND SEE IF WE CAN GET A WIN WIN.
I DON'T THINK I ANSWERED ALL
YOUR QUESTIONS OF WHAT HAPPENED
TO THAT THAT'S- NOT A MATTER
VICE CHAIR BY MAY- YOU KNOW
BUILD ON THE LET THEM PLAY
COMMENTS THIS IS KIM TURNER
WITH FAIR PLAY FOR GIRLS IN
SPORTS I HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME
BUT- I ALSO HAVE. A SEVEN YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER WHO WOULD LOVE TO
BE PLAYING YOUTH SPORTS RIGHT
NOW AND- A TWO YEAR OLD SON.
WHO'S LOOKING FORWARD TO TALK
SOCCER YOU KNOW AND- I AM UP
HERE IN THE BAY AREA AND I JUST
WANT TO CHIME IN AND SAY. I AM
DESPERATE TO SEE ARGUED BACK ON
THE FIELD IN THE GYMS IN A SAFE
MANNER- AND I'VE TALKED A LOT
WITH PARKS AND REC AND I
APPRECIATE MATT DOHERTY'S
COMMENTS. TODAY ABOUT HOW MUCH
PARKS AND REC- SUFFERING RIGHT
NOW. BUT I ALSO THINK THAT OUR
LOCAL WONDERFUL PARKS AND REC
FOLKS CAN WORK TO MAKE SURE
VULNERABLE YOUTH ARE EXERCISING
ARE GETTING SPORTS CONDITIONING
OPPORTUNITIES. AS MUCH AS THEY
CAN IN A SAFE MANNER AND MAKING
SURE GIRLS ARE JUST AS WELCOME
BACK BECAUSE I SEE A LOT OF POP
WARNER. FOOTBALL IN LITTLE
LEAGUE BASEBALL JUMPING TO GET
BACK BUT NOT AS MUCH. EMPHASIS
ON THE GIRLS YOUNG GIRL'S
SPORTS GETTING BACK OR THE CODE
SPORTS GETTING BACK SO JUST
MAKING SURE THERE'S A GENDER
LENS. ON MAKING SURE ALL YOUTH
REGARDLESS OF GENDER CAN GET
BACK INTO THOSE COMMUNITIES
PORTS IS KEY. AND THEN ALSO
JUST SAVE. THE PRIVATE
EXPENSIVE SPORTS ARE PRICING
OUT A LOT OF LOW INCOME KIDS SO
LITTLE BOYS AND GIRLS CAN'T
ALWAYS AFFORD A THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A CLUB SPORT- YOU
KNOW IT'S GOTTEN SO EXPENSIVE
SO I THINK IF OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS CAN ENSURE
THERE'S- SCHOLARSHIPS. AND
EQUITABLE ACCESSIBLE AFFORDABLE
YOUTH SPORTS CONDITIONING AND
WORKOUT OPPORTUNITIES THAT'S
GOING TO FIGHT THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS THAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW SUFFERING. A SUMMER
BY OUR KIDS I THINK THAT
COMMENTED I HOPE YOUR GIRL GETS
BACK OUT THERE TO PLAY VERY
SOON AND ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
KIDS THANK YOU. AND THEN ONE
MORE QUESTION MANAGER IF YOU
DON'T MIND. FOR MY PHONE YES-
AS I MENTIONED- EARLIER IS A-
DIRECTOR OF. SPEAKS OUR BROTHER
BUTTER WERE WALL. AND THE
AUTISM SPEAKS WALK FROM
PASADENA RAISE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR THE
AUTISM COMMUNITY. DO YOU HAVE
ANY YOU KNOW- NUMBERS ARE ON
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT FOR. OUR
NOT OUR NONPROFITS LIKE AUTISM
SPEAKS OR- TO- YOU KNOW APPLE
UP SEE. ALL OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PUT ON WALKS
IS THEIR MAJOR MEANS OF REVENUE
BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO HAVE A
RIPPLE EFFECT. FOR INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL JUST NEEDS
COMMUNITY. FOR CANCER TREATMENT
SERVICES AND THERAPIES. THIS IS
GONNA BE A HUGE ECONOMIC IMPACT
AND I'D LOVE TO KNOW IF YOU
HAVE ANY DATA. ON IT OR IF YOU
COULD FOLLOW UP WITH ANY DATA
THAT EXIST ON IT ON THE ON THE
RIPPLE EFFECT AND ECONOMIC
IMPACT. SURE THE. THE IMPACT AS
I MENTIONED AS A THEN ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ESTIMATE
A SEVENTY MILLION DOLLAR.
REVENUE GENERATION TO NONPROFIT
SPECIFICALLY THROUGH ENDURANCE
EVENTS. SOME OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING THEY'VE BEEN
HAPPENING AT DIFFERENT EVELS
WHERE THEY HAVE A NOT LIFE
EVENTS BUT THEY'LL HAVE A
VIRTUAL EVENT AND THEY'RE-
RECEIVING A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
WHAT THEY NORMALLY MAY. BY IN
ADDITION AUTISM SPEAKS WE HAVE
CLIENTS THAT WE WORK WITH THOSE
THE SUSAN G. KOMEN FOUNDATION
AND THE- DD HIRSCH MENTAL
HEALTH CENTER RAISING MONEY FOR
SOME TEENAGE SUICIDE
PREVENTION. AND THESE EVENTS
ARE HAPPENING AND NOT ONLY IS
THAT THE ECONOMIC IMPACT AS YOU
CAN APPRECIATE IT'S ALSO THE
MARKET THE MESSAGING IMPACT.
WHEN YOU CAN BRING TOGETHER.
TEN TWENTY THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE ALL THE FOR- AN AMERICAN
HEART WALK OR- SUICIDE
PREVENTION YOU GET THAT MESSAGE
SO JEALOUS PEOPLE AND YOU RAISE
THE MONEY. I'D BE HAPPY TO
SLICE UP THE ECONOMIC IMPACT I
DON'T HAVE HER- BECAUSE FOR
NONPROFIT HANDY BUT IT IS A
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLAR ECONOMIC
ENGINE THAT'S GENERATED THROUGH
AND THEIR EXPORTS. THINK BACK.
YOU NUMBERS EVEN WHEN THOSE
COME BACK. THE LONGER WE PUT
OFF THE HARDER IT'S GOING TO BE
TO BRING HIM BACK IN AND THE
SLOWER IT'S GOING TO BE TO
BRING UP. ABSOLUTELY AND I
WOULD JUST YOU KNOW MENTION NOT
YOU KNOW HAVING PLANNED. MANY
MANY WALKS IN MY LIFETIME- IT
IS AN INTRICATE PROCESS AND IT
REQUIRES TIME. AND THE MORE
GUIDANCE THE MORE. LEAD TIME WE
CAN GIVE ORGANIZATIONS TO GET
THESE. EVENTS CALENDAR AND- IN
PROCESS THAT THE BETTER THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR. FOR YOUR FOR
BEING A PART OF A PANEL SAY.
YOU'RE WELCOME THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WE ARE
CHECKING- IN THE QUEUE OF
PUBLIC COMMENTS AND- WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE WELL WE ARE DOING
NOT. I WILL JUST MAKE A FEW
AGAIN COMMENTS THAT ARE RELATED
TO SPORTS BUT ALSO UNDER THE
ARTS AND ENTERTAINMENT UMBRELLA
WE'VE HAD WE'VE TAKEN CALLS%
THIS WEEK AGAIN. AND AGAIN BRAD
HENSLEY YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB
BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE GROUPS
SPRINGING UP THAT WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT LET THEIR STUDENTS
PERFORM MEANING BAND STUDENTS
MEANING- THEATER STUDENTS AND
AGAIN WE KNOW THAT WHATEVER IT
IS THE ELECTIVE FOR. OUR K.
TWELVE STUDENTS WHETHER IT'S
BANNED DANCING SPORTS THEY ARE
WEDDED READY THEY'RE WILLING
AND WE AS A STATE NEED TO GET
MOVING LITERALLY MOVING GET IT.
NO BUT- ONE OF OUR PANELS A
WHILE BACK. ON OUR HEARTS-
ORCHESTRA DIRECTOR FROM ORANGE
COUNTY SEGERSTROM ANOTHER MAJOR
ART INSTITUTION THAT WANTS TO
KNOW WHEN THEY'RE CAN GET BACK
TO PLANNING A FULL SEASON SAID.
QUOTE IS CALIFORNIA GOING TO BE
A LEADER OR A LIGER AND WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE THE- MOST
INTENSIVE PROTOCOLS. AND THAT
BEEN IMPORTANT AS MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE HAVE DIED PARTICULARLY
IN OUR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY
FRONTLINE WORKERS. BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT MORE AND MORE PEOPLE
ARE RECEIVING THE VACCINE. WE
KNOW THE NUMBERS ARE GOING DOWN
AND SO AT IT IS TIME TO GET OUR
ATHLETES OR PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETES ARE YOUNG ADULTS OUR
CHILDREN ARE PRE K. KIDS WHO
HAVEN'T EVEN STARTED TO TUMBLE
ABOUT. OUT THERE DOING WHAT
THEY DO BEST AND THAT'S MOVING-
SO HOW WE GONNA DO THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS THERE AREN'T ANY IN
THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL
KEEP I THINK THE PHONES OPEN TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE. THOSE
REMARKS IF THEY COME IN ON
RECORD I DO WANNA. AND THEY CAN
RESET- SUBMIT ANY COMMENTS TO
OUR WEBSITE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE GO ON THE PUBLIC RECORD I
DO WANT TO IT THANK OUR
EXTENSIVE GROUP OF EXPERT
PANELISTS YOU KNOW EVERY TIME
I'VE DONE THIS IS MY THIRD
HEARING UNDER. THIS UMBRELLA
AND I REALLY DO LEARN SOMETHING
AND IN FACT IT MANY MANY TIMES
WILL MANIFEST ITSELF INTO A
BILL LIKE ARE AB FOUR TWENTY
WITH OUR VICE CHAIR HERE WHERE
WE FEEL. THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
HIS TEAM AND OTHERS LISTENED
AND WE'VE HAD A LITTLE REPRIEVE
WITH THEME PARKS NOW STARTING
TO SET DATES FOR OPENING SO
CERTAINLY IF THEME PARKS CAN
START TO OPEN AND RESTAURANTS
WE GOT TO GET THOSE A KIDS
PLAYING BASEBALL BOXING
SWIMMING. I'M NOT GOING TO
START LISTING BECAUSE THEY GO
DOWN THE LIST BUT- WE
APPRECIATE YOU AND WE'RE AT OUR
BEST WHEN WE HAVE KIDS PLAYING
ON THE FIELD AND WE KNOW IT'S
GOOD FOR THEIR HEALTH THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND THE SONS ARE
HEARING. THANK YOU EVERYONE.